Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Corfu, 8 May 1909 Dearest Nicky, As Hintzer is returning for your birthday, I gladly seize the opportunity to send you these lights. With all my heart, I wish you many happy returns. May heaven bless and protect you and your wife and children.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。克基拉岛，1909年5月8日，最亲爱的尼基：趁着欣策（Hintzer）要回去给你过生日，我高兴地抓住这个机会把这些灯送给你。我由衷地祝你福寿绵长。愿上帝保佑并庇护你、你的妻子和孩子们。
May you be successful in your work for your country and the welfare of your people. Will you kindly accept as birthday present a watercolor sketch made by a clever Coffey painter representing the Achilleon seen from the olive grove at the foot of the hill. We spent a lovely time there under a blue sky, surrounded by sweet scents and flowers, sitting on the marble terraces in the shade of fine palm trees. Oh, I hope that once I may be able to show you this paradise when you chance to be yachting in the Mediterranean. Oh, the island is lovely
愿你在为国家和人民福利的工作中取得成功。能否请你接受一块由一位聪明的科菲画家创作的水彩画素描作为生日礼物？画中描绘的是从山脚下橄榄园望见的阿基里斯宫。我们在那里度过了一段美好的时光：头顶是蓝天，四周环绕着芬芳的香气和鲜花，坐在细长棕榈树荫下的大理石露台上。哦，我希望有朝一日，当你碰巧在地中海开游艇时，我能向你展示这处人间天堂。哦，这座岛屿很可爱，
and the people quiet, simple and very polite. And no tourists. Now, goodbye, dearest Nicky. Best love to Alex and the children, especially the boy. God bless and protect you. Au revoir, Nicky. Best love to Alex and the children, especially the boy.
人们也很安静、纯朴、十分懂礼貌。而且没有游客。好了，再见，最亲爱的尼基。代我向亚历克斯和孩子们致以最美好的爱意，尤其是那个男孩。愿上帝保佑并庇护你。再见，尼基。代我向亚历克斯和孩子们致以最美好的爱意，尤其是那个男孩。
God bless and protect you. Au revoir, I hope. And believe me, ever, your most affectionate and devoted friend and cousin, Philly.
愿上帝保佑并庇护你。再见，但愿如此。相信我，永远是你最深情、最忠诚的朋友兼表弟，菲利（Philly）。
So, Dominic, that is a most charming letter, isn't it? It is. Full of love of flowers, of the landscape of beautiful Corfu, generosity of spirit. Watercolours. Yeah. And people may be wondering, who is this charming man
那么，多米尼克，这是一封极其迷人的信，对吧？确实如此。充满了对鲜花的喜爱、对美丽克基拉岛风景的赞美，以及宽广的精神胸怀。水彩画。是的。人们可能会好奇，这位迷人的男士是谁呢？
who has sent this delightful letter, this lover of watercolours, of the flowers of Greece? And it's our old friend, the Kaiser. It is. It is. Who appears in a very unexpected light at times, isn't he, in this series? Well, we've already had him going around gardens. With Franz Ferdinand.
他送出了这封令人愉悦的信，这位水彩画爱好者、希腊花卉的爱好者？他就是我们的老朋友，德皇。没错，就是他。在这部系列中，他有时会以一种非常出人意料的形象出现，不是吗？嗯，我们之前已经讲过他带着弗朗茨·斐迪南去逛花园。
So we know that this is part of his character. And of course, this is a reminder that the Kaiser and the Tsar, they're the heads of these two bristling war machines, but they're also cousins. They are. And there's this whole series of messages. They're famously called the Nikki Vili telegrams. And we will be coming back to these messages later in this episode. They have been sending for many years. So this one is five years before the outbreak of war. These messages are kind of semi-public, semi-private. All the stuff about give my love to Alex and the children, that's obviously a private and genuine message. But foreign office officials would help the various emperors draft these messages and put in them
所以我们知道这是他性格的一部分。当然，这也提醒我们，德皇和沙皇虽然是这两台剑拔弩张的战争机器的元首，但他们也是表兄弟。确实如此。这里有一整串的信息。它们有个著名的名字叫“尼基-维利电报”。我们将在本集的后面再次谈到这些信息。他们已经发送了很多年。所以这封信是在战争爆发前五年写的。这些消息半公半私。所有关于“代我向亚历克斯和孩子们问好”之类的话，显然是私人且真诚的问候。但外交部的官员会协助各路皇帝起草这些信息，并在其中加入
sentiments about avoiding war and about settling diplomatic disputes and so on. There's a couple of other interesting things in this one, which I found online. So Kaiser says in this letter, he says, when I went to Corfu, I was really looking forward to a proper holiday because I worked so hard. And then he says, but when we got there, we found out there's a revolution in Constantinople. So I had to do lots of paperwork. And he says to him, we poor rulers, it seems are not entitled to holidays like other simple mortals. The note of self-pity is so amusing. And then the other thing that appealed to me, the Kaiser is furious. He says, the papers, I work for peace, as do you. But the newspapers are always stirring up antagonism between our two countries.
关于避免战争、解决外交争端等言论。这封信里还有另外几个有趣的内容，我是网上找到的。德皇在这封信里说，他说，当我前往克基拉岛时，我真的很期待一个真正的假期，因为我工作太辛苦了。然后他说，但当我们到达那里时，我们发现君士坦丁堡爆发了革命。所以我不得不处理大量的文书工作。他对他说，我们这些可怜的统治者，看来是没有资格像其他凡夫俗子那样度假的。这种自怜的语气真是太有趣了。然后吸引我的另一件事是，德皇非常愤怒。他说，报纸上说，我为和平而工作，你也是。但报纸总是在我们两国之间煽动对立。
And he says, a lot of newspaper writers, a lot of commentators and columnists just are completely ignorant. But more dangerous and at the same time more loathsome is that part of the press which writes what it is paid for. They incite the hostility of one nation against another, and when at last through the hellish devices they have brought about the much-desired collision, they placidly sit down to watch the fight. So Dominic, as an erstwhile columnist in the Daily Mail and a columnist in the Times, do you feel seen by the Kaiser? A sting of reproach? I do, yeah. I feel judged by the Kaiser. That's not a good position to be in. Good. Yeah. The thing that strikes me about this is that actually
他说，许多报纸撰稿人、许多评论员和专栏作家完全是无知的。但更危险、同时又更令人厌恶的是那部分拿钱发文的媒体。他们煽动一个国家对另一个国家的敌意，当他们终于通过那些地狱般的诡计引发了梦寐以求的冲突时，他们却安然坐下观赏这场厮杀。那么，多米尼克，作为《每日邮报》的前专栏作家和《泰晤士报》的专栏作家，你觉得德皇是在说你吗？有一种被指责刺痛的感觉吗？确实有，是的。我觉得自己受到了德皇的审判。这不是一个好处境。很好。是的。这件事让我感触最深的是，其实
it's a reminder of how close he is to Austria because the Achilleion that he mentions, this is a tremendous palace, about 10 miles perhaps from the main city in Corfu. And it was the palace that Sisi, the Princess Diana of the Austro-Hungarian Empire, the wife of Emperor Franz Joseph and the mother of Prince Rudolf, who shot himself and thereby enabled Franz Ferdinand to become the heir to the throne. That's where she retired and lived. And the Kaiser absolutely loves it. Have you been to it? Have you seen it? No, I've never been to Corfu.
它提醒我们，他与奥地利的关系有多么亲密，因为他提到的阿基里斯宫是一座宏伟的宫殿，距离克基拉岛的主城大约有10英里远。这座宫殿曾是茜茜公主的居所——她堪称奥匈帝国的戴安娜王妃，是弗朗茨·约瑟夫皇帝的妻子、鲁道夫王储的母亲；鲁道夫自杀身亡，从而让弗朗茨·斐迪南成为了皇位继承人。那是她退隐和生活的地方。德皇对这里喜爱至极。你去过那里吗？你见过吗？没有，我从未去过克基拉岛。
In the garden. I mean, it's a beautiful place. It really is gorgeous. And the Kaiser is not exaggerating about the beauty of its flowers. But out in the garden, there is an enormous statue of Achilles. So hence the name, the great Greek warrior, with a very, very skimpy kind of mini skirt. So he's dressed as a hoplite.
在花园里。我的意思是，那是个美丽的地方。真的太华丽了。而且德皇关于那里繁花似锦的赞美一点也没有夸张。但是在花园外面，有一尊巨大的阿基里斯雕像。因此这座宫殿才叫这个名字，这位伟大的希腊勇士穿着一条非常非常暴露的迷你裙。他打扮成了一个重装步兵。
And, you know, you're upskirting. Right. It's very difficult to avoid gazing up at the buttocks. Well, that would put to bed all those questions that floated around in Berlin newspapers about the seameer side of the Kaiser's inner circle. That would resolve that. Exactly. And the inscription on that sculpture, although it's no longer there, but it's brilliant. It's to the greatest Greek from the greatest German.
然后，你知道的，你在偷窥裙底。没错。要想不盯着那些臀部看实在太难了。好吧，这就会彻底平息柏林报纸上流传的那些关于德皇内圈“海面侧面”（同性恋倾向）的种种质疑了。那就能解决这个问题了。没错。那座雕塑上的铭文虽然现在已经不在了，但非常绝妙。那是“致最伟大的希腊人，来自最伟大的德国人”。
Oh. So tremendous modesty. Great modesty from the Kaiser. And he's actually there. He goes to Corfu, I think, pretty much every year. And he was there in 1914. Really? So his happy place, I think.
哦。真是无比谦逊。德皇表现出了极大的谦逊。而且他确实常去那里。我想他几乎每年都去克基拉岛。1914年他也去过。真的吗？所以这是他的快乐老家吧。
So in the past, you know, they have written to each other expressing their love of peace and promising to work together and all that kind of thing. But obviously, they've never faced a situation like this one. So we ended last time with the expiry of the Austrian ultimatum on Saturday, the 25th of July, scenes of celebration in Vienna. And yes, of course, at this point, the Austrians have still not fired a shot. So the next day, Sunday, the 26th, they meet at about midday or the Austrian high command and the foreign minister, what they say to General Conrad, who's been pressing for war
所以在过去，你知道的，他们互相写信表达对和平的热爱，承诺共同努力诸如此类。但很显然，他们从未面对过这样一种局面。所以上集我们讲到了奥地利最后通牒在7月25日星期六到期，维也纳一片欢庆景象。当然，此时此刻，奥地利人还没有开过一枪。所以在第二天，即26日星期日，大约中午时分，奥地利最高指挥部和外交部长开会，他们对一直催促战争的康拉德将军说了什么呢？
all this time. Right. Are you ready? And he says, I know, we're going to have to wait until 1922. Yeah, he says, I'm kind of ready. I think we should probably start in mid-August would be ideal for me. That would suit me. Would that work for you?
好啦。你们准备好了吗？然后他说，我知道，我们得等到1922年才行。是的，他说，我差不多准备好了。我觉得我们大概应该在八月中旬开始，这对我来说最理想。那正合我意。这对你合适吗？
And they're like, what? They thought he was going to start straight away. So actually, across Europe, there is a sense, even after they expire the ultimatum, we can work this out, we can get back from this. So if you'd stopped the clock at that point, Sunday the 26th of July, and said to some of these policymakers, will there be a world war? I think a lot of them would have said there might, but I'm hopeful, I have to be optimistic that we can somehow sort all this out. So for example, we talked last time about Sir Edward Grey, the British Foreign Secretary. He has put on the table a scheme for mediation, which is basically, you know,
他们当时就想：什么？他们以为他会马上开始呢。所以实际上，在整个欧洲，甚至在最后通牒过期之后，依然有一种感觉：我们能解决这个问题，我们还能从中退回。所以如果你把时钟在那个时间点停下——7月26日星期日，并且问其中的某些决策者：会有世界大战吗？我想他们中的很多人会说可能会，但我抱有希望，我必须保持乐观，相信我们能以某种方式把这一切理顺。比如，我们上期谈到了英国外交大臣爱德华·格雷。他提出了一个调解方案，基本上就是，
there'll be a sort of court, as it were, of Britain, France, Germany, and Italy, and they will adjudicate the dispute between Austria and Serbia. Of course, what he doesn't know is that the window of opportunity for that, insofar it ever existed, is closing very fast as the different nations are kind of hardening their position. And the next day, the Monday, the 27th, the Germans are pretty clear that they will never go along with this. And they say, look, we cannot support this because we will be dragging our one ally and friend before a court. Like, it needs to be arbitrated.
会有由英国、法国、德国和意大利组成的一个类似法庭的机构，由他们来裁决奥地利和塞尔维亚之间的争端。当然，他不知道的是，这种努力的窗口期（如果它曾经存在过的话）正在随着各国立场的日渐强硬而飞速关闭。到了第二天，即27日星期一，德国人态度相当明确：他们绝不会同意这个方案。他们说，听着，我们不能支持这个方案，因为这意味着我们要把我们唯一的盟友和朋友拉上法庭受审。这需要进行仲裁。
And actually, the Austrians have been very hard done by it. The air has been shot. They are entitled to take defensive measures. And I think you get the first sense that day, which is the Monday, that Gray himself is beginning to lose patience and to realize that actually this might not be a success. So he actually makes it public for the first time. He goes into the Commons and says, this is my plan. I want to have a conference in London. I want to mediate. And he says, again, giving the lie to those critics who say old men took the world into war and they thought it'd be over by Christmas and it would be a great laugh and a jamboree. Gray says explicitly, if we don't get this right, if we don't sort it out, it will end in the
实际上，奥地利人受了很大的委屈。大公已经被杀害了。他们有权采取防御性措施。我想你从那一天的星期一就能隐约感觉到，格雷本人也开始失去耐心，意识到这可能不会成功。所以他实际上是第一次将其公之于众。他走进下议院说：这就是我的计划。我希望在伦敦召开一次会议。我希望进行调解。他说——这再次驳斥了那些批评者的谎言，那些人说老头子们把世界拖入了战争，还以为到圣诞节就能结束，认为那会是一场好玩的狂欢——格雷明确指出：如果我们不能正确处理这件事，如果我们不能解决它，它将以欧洲大陆有史以来遭遇的最大灾难而告终。
greatest catastrophe that has ever befallen the continent of Europe. You know, in the cabinet, when they talk about it that evening in Britain, the mood is very gloomy. And actually, a lot of the liberals say, a guy called John Burns, who was the president of the World Trade, why four great powers should fight over Serbia, no fellow can understand. But four, not five. Right. Four, not five. Exactly. And what about Asquith? Is he still kind of chilling out, hanging out with his girlfriend? Asquith is very chilled because he's, of course, thinking about his relationship with Venetia Stanley all this time. We talked about that a little bit in a previous episode. He's completely besotted this summer with Venetia. After the
你知道的，那天晚上英国内阁开会讨论此事时，气氛非常阴沉。实际上，许多自由党人——比如一个叫约翰·伯恩斯的人，他是世界贸易的主席——说：为什么四个大国要为塞尔维亚打仗，谁也搞不懂。但是四个，不是五个。对。四个，不是五个。没错。那阿斯奎斯呢？他还在那儿悠闲地跟女朋友厮混吗？阿斯奎斯非常悠闲，因为他这段时间满脑子都是他和威尼斯·斯坦利的关系。我们在之前的节目中稍微聊过这个。这个夏天他完全被威尼斯迷住了。内阁会议结束后，
cabinet meeting, he writes to her and he says, we had this cabinet meeting. I mean, it's unbelievable that he's betraying all these secrets. She's even really his girlfriend i mean she's his daughter's friend and he says gray wants to have this conference the germans don't want to do it the only real hope is that austria and russia may come to a deal but then he ends the letter that's a pretty quiet evening at the house i'm actually going to get violent that's his daughter to beat up one or two people to dine at home and play bridge so you know I'm actually going to get Violet, that's his daughter, to beat up one or two people to dine at home and play bridge. So, you know, I'm not going to let this bother me.
他写信给她说：我们刚开完内阁会议。我的意思是，他泄露这么多机密简直难以置信。她甚至真的是他的女朋友吗？我的意思是，她是她女儿的朋友。他接着说：格雷想要开这个会，德国人不想干，唯一的真实希望是奥地利和俄罗斯能达成协议。但随后他信的结尾写道：今晚在宅邸度过了一个相当安静的夜晚，我其实打算让维奥莱特去揍一两个人，在家里吃晚饭然后打桥牌，所以，你知道的——我其实打算让维奥莱特（那是他的女儿）去揍一两个人，在家里吃晚饭然后打桥牌。所以，你知道的，我不会让这事儿烦心。
I'm not going to distract me from my important card games routine. I mean, to be fair, you might say it's better that he's fresh. I mean, there's no point in working himself to death over this. Don't work too hard. That's absolutely my attitude, Tom. You know my views on Asquith. I do. I think that's his admirable sang-froid from an absolutely tip-top prime minister.
这不会让我分心，不耽误我玩纸牌游戏的日常。我的意思是，平心而论，你可能会说他保持精力充沛是件好事。我的意思是，为此把自己累死毫无意义。别太拼了。汤姆，这绝对是我的态度。你知道我对阿斯奎斯的看法。我知道。我认为这是一个绝佳首相所表现出的令人钦佩的沉着冷静。
And I applaud it. I like it. Okay. All right. But maybe we should bring the Kaiser back onto stage. We should. Because this is very exciting. Because he's been on his holiday, hasn't he, in the fjords?
我为之喝彩。我很喜欢。好吧。好吧。但也许我们该把德皇请回舞台上了。我们应该这样做。因为这太令人兴奋了。因为他一直在峡湾度假，不是吗？
Yes. And the only time I've been to Norway, we went to the hotel where they have the chair that he was sitting on when news was brought to him saying, you've got to come back because things are getting out of control oh did you sit in it yeah i did i sat in it and did you did you feel the weight of the kaiser's i communed yeah i felt possessed by his spirit and this is why as you say i've turned into the kaiser well tom this is such a great subject for you you've got sir edward gray's hat or a simulacrum of it yeah you went to his cottage or the site of it and you've sat in the Kaiser's chair.
是的。我唯一一次去挪威时，我们去了一家酒店，里面有把椅子——当消息传到他那里、告诉他“你得回去了，因为局势失控了”时，他当时就坐在那把椅子上。哦，你坐了吗？是的，我坐了。我坐在上面，你有没有感受到德皇的——我交流了。是的，我觉得被他的灵魂附体了。这就是为什么正如你所说，我变成了德皇。好吧，汤姆，这对你来说真是一个绝佳的主题：你有爱德华·格雷爵士的帽子，或者它的复制品；你去过他的乡间小屋或遗址，你还坐过德皇的椅子。
Yeah. Incredible. So you have a real insight. This is personal for you. Yeah, I really do. And this is why I have such a handle on the whole episode. Yeah. Because I can see from both sides, Dominic.
是的。太不可思议了。所以你有着真正的深刻见解。这对你来说很私密。是的，我确实有。这就是为什么我对整段历史有着如此强的掌控力。是的。因为我能从双方的角度来看待问题，多米尼克。
Well, that's commendable. Yeah. So the Kaiser has been away for three weeks on his yacht, the Hohenzollern. He's been to the Kiel Regatta and there's been loads of great larks and bants with Royal Navy officers there. So no sign of Anglo-German antagonism at the regatta. It's all been smiles and sort of handshakes and stuff. And then he's gone off to Norway.
嗯，这值得赞赏。是的。所以德皇已经在他的游艇“霍亨索伦号”上离开三个星期了。他去参加了基尔帆船赛，在那里和皇家海军军官们进行了大量的欢声笑语和玩笑互动。所以在帆船赛上根本没有英德对立的迹象。到处都是微笑和握手之类的事情。然后他就去了挪威。
Now, all this time, he has been interested in the case because he's been telegraphing, as is always his way. He's been sending unwanted advice to other European royals. Yeah, well, that never happens because when I go on holiday, I never send messages or emails, say, about the podcast ever. Yeah, unwanted advice where people reply saying, Tom, you're on holiday, pipe down. That Kaiser parallel uncanny.
现在，在这段时间里，他一直对这件事很感兴趣，因为他一直在拍电报，一如既往地。他一直在向其他欧洲王室成员发送没人想要的建议。是的，嗯，这从来不会发生，因为当我度假时，我绝不会发送关于播客的任何消息或电子邮件。从来没有。是的，那些别人不想要却硬要给的建议，结果别人回复说：汤姆，你在度假，闭嘴吧。德皇的这种相似性真诡异。
So the Kaiser still believes in all this time that there won't be a general war. There is no doubt about that. When they present him, so when he's in that chair and they present him with the text of the ultimatum, he says to the head of his naval staff, Admiral Muller, he says, well, what do you know? It's a firm note after all. In other words, he's surprised that the Austrians have not just wimped out a bit, which he seems to have expected them to do. Admiral Muller says, I actually think this could mean war. I don't see how we back down from this.
所以德皇在这段里依然相信不会爆发全面战争。毫无疑问。当他们把最后通牒的文本呈递给他——当时他就坐在那把椅子上——他对其海军参谋长穆勒海军上将说：“你瞧怎么着？这终究是一份措辞坚定的照会。”换句话说，他对奥地利人没有直接怂掉感到意外，而他似乎原本预料他们会怂的。穆勒海军上将说：“我实际上认为这可能意味着战争。我看不出我们怎么能从这事儿里退缩。”
And Wilhelm says, oh, no, no, no. The Serbs would never risk a war against Austria and the Russians would never pile in. And Admiral Muller thinks at the time he is deluding himself because he just cannot bring himself to contemplate the reality. Because he's such a man of peace. He's a blusterer. He's Mr. Toad. Because when it comes to it, actually, he will always try to back away. Now, we will see in this story whether this
威廉则说：“哦，不，不，不。塞尔维亚人绝不敢冒着与奥地利开战的风险，俄罗斯人也绝不敢插手。”穆勒海军上将当时觉得他在自欺欺人，因为他根本无法迫使自己去面对现实。因为他是如此热爱和平的人。他是个虚张声势的人。他是蟾蜍先生。因为真到了关键时刻，他其实总是会试图退缩。现在，我们将在接下来的故事中看到是不是这样，
is what happens, whether the Kaiser does indeed try to back away. So on Monday the 27th, so it's now a day and a half after the expiry of the ultimatum, he arrives back in Germany. His Chancellor, Theobald Bethmann-Holweg, has said to him, please don't come to Berlin. Don't come into the center of the city. There will be demonstrations of support for you. There will be very excited crowds who think that you're coming back to declare war or something. We can't afford anything like that. You go to your palace in Potsdam. And the Kaiser is very displeased about this.
德皇是否真的试图退缩。所以在7月27日星期一——也就是最后通牒过期后的一天半，他回到了德国。他的宰相特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格对他说：“请不要来柏林。不要来市中心。那里会有游行支持你，会有非常兴奋的人群，他们会以为你是回来宣战什么的。我们承担不起这样的后果。你去你在波茨坦的宫殿吧。”德皇对此非常不满。
He says, this is getting madder. Now that man instructs me, I may not show myself to my people. But he does as he's told. He goes to his palace and everybody there, the general sense is, you know, this is going to be a bit tricky, but there will not be a world war. His aide to camp, his adjutant, Hans von Plessen, writes in his diary, you know, the Austrians aren't even ready to get going. We hope to localize the war. England declares that she wishes to remain neutral. This is the belief in Berlin at this point.
他说：“这越来越荒唐了。现在连那个人也要指示我，不准我在我的臣民面前露面。”但他还是照办了。他去了他的宫殿，每个人在那里的普遍感觉是，你知道的，这可能会有点棘手，但不会爆发世界大战。他的副官、侍从武官汉斯·冯·普莱森在日记中写道，你知道的，“奥地利人甚至还没准备好开打。我们希望能把战争局限化。英国宣称她希望保持中立。”柏林当时就是这么坚信的。
You know, they have listened to Prince Lichnowsky telling them, oh, Edward Grey feels a bit of sympathy for Austria. He doesn't want a war. And so they tell themselves the British are definitely going to stay out. And Hans von Plessen writes, I have the impression that nothing much will come of this matter. Which almost exactly echoes Asquith. Yeah, exactly. So this is what they are all telling themselves.
你知道，他们听信了利希诺夫斯基亲王的话，以为爱德华·格雷对奥地利有点同情心，他不想打仗。所以他们自我安慰说英国人绝对会作壁上观。于是汉斯·冯·普莱森写道：“我有种印象，这件事不会有什么大不了的结果。”这几乎跟阿斯奎斯的想法如出一辙。是的，完全一样。所以这就是他们所有人都在自我安慰的内容。
Now, they have, of course, bargained without the Kaiser wading in. He can't stop himself. Like you, Tom, he gets up very early. So on Tuesday, the 28th of July, he's also a sportsman, like you. Yeah. He goes riding every day at 7.30 in the morning. Commendable behaviour. But before then, he always does his paperwork.
现在，他们当然没有把德皇的横插一脚算在内。他根本管不住自己。就像你一样，汤姆，他起得很早。所以7月28日星期星期二，他也是个体育爱好者，跟你一样。是的。他每天早上七点半去骑马。值得称赞的行为。但在此之前，他总是先处理公文。
Again, commendable behaviour. He's dutiful. And he goes through all the paperwork from three weeks while he always does his paperwork. Again, commendable behavior. He's dutiful. And he goes through all the paperwork from three weeks while he's been on holiday. And towards the bottom is the Serbian reply to the ultimatum. Chris Clark, I think, calls it a perfumed rejection of the Austrian. The Kaiser, because he's a bit of a fool, opens it and says, oh my God, this is unbelievable. I can't believe this.
同样值得称赞的行为。他很有责任感。他审阅了度假三周以来的所有公文。同样值得称赞的行为。他很有责任感。他审阅了度假三周以来的所有公文。而在文件堆的底部，是塞尔维亚对最后通牒的回复。克里斯·克拉克，我想，称之为对奥地利人的一封“喷了香水的拒绝信”。德皇因为有点糊涂，打开信看了便说：“哦，天哪，这太难以置信了。我简直不敢相信。
The Serbians have accepted everything. And he actually says, and and i quote a brilliant achievement for a deadline of a mere 48 hours this is more than one could expect a great moral victory for vienna it removes every reason for war and he says that the austrian ambassador giesel could have stayed in belgrade well i would never have ordered mobilization in response the austrians haven't actually ordered mobilization at this point but this is somebody it seems to me that the very hostile view of the Kaiser that you get from, say, his biographer John C. Ruhl, who says, oh, the Kaiser's a monster and he's itching for war. These aren't the words to me of a man itching for war. These are actually the words of a man who can't wait to grab the chance of peace. I agree. I mean, I think he's coming out of this much, much better than I had
塞尔维亚人竟然全盘接受了。”他甚至说——我引述原话：“对于短短48小时的最后期限来说，这是一项堪称辉煌的成就。这比任何人所能期望的还要多，这是维也纳的一个巨大道德胜利，它消除了开战的一切理由。”他说奥地利大使吉塞尔本可以留在贝尔格莱德的。要是我的话，绝不会下达总动员令来作为回应。奥地利人此时其实并未下达动员令，但这反映出——在我看来，那些对德皇抱有极度敌意的人（比如他的传记作家约翰·C·鲁尔，他说“德皇是个怪物，他渴望战争”）的说法是站不住脚的。这些话绝不是一个渴望战争的人会说的话。这些其实是一个迫不及待想要抓住和平机会的人的话。我同意。我的表现比我预期的要好得多，
anticipated. Yeah. And other historians, so even ones who are coming out of this much, much better than I had anticipated. Yeah. And other historians, so even ones who are quite critical of the Kaiser, let's say Thomas Otte in his book, July Crisis, he says, when it comes to this, the Kaiser actually shows much more common sense and intelligence than many of his much better educated, more intelligent officials. Yeah. Because, I mean, the Austrians could have said, well, this is a win. Yeah.
我是说，我觉得他在这件事上的表现比我预期的要好得多。是的。其他历史学家——甚至是对德皇颇多批评的历史学家，比如托马斯·奥特在他的书《七月危机》中也说，当谈到这一点时，德皇实际上表现出了比他那些受过更好教育、更聪明的官员们更多的常识和智商。是的。因为，我的意思是，奥地利人本可以宣称：“这是一场胜利。
You accept that we're right. Okay, fine. Yeah. And we'll take you at your word. And actually, we will take you to court. You know, we will insist on holding you to account for every last jot of your perfumed acceptances or rejections of our points. Because doesn't the Kaiser suggest this?
你们承认了我们是对的。好吧，就这样。是的。我们就按你们说的办。实际上，我们要跟你们讲理。你知道的，我们会坚持要求你们为我们提出的每一个有香水味的接受或拒绝的条款负责到底。”因为德皇不就是这么建议的吗？
Yes. He says, well, why don't you just, you know, say, yeah, we've won. Yeah. He's not wrong, right? Now, the thing is, his aide-de-camp, they're out riding and the Kaiser makes this point. And his aide-de-camp says, people aren't idiots. The Austrians need something tangible. They need something to show their public
是的。他说：“好吧，你们为什么不说：‘太好了，我们赢了。’呢？”他没有错，对吧？现在的问题是，他的副官正在外面骑马，德皇提出了这个观点。他的副官说：“大家可不是傻子。奥地利人需要点实质性的东西。他们需要向公众证明
that they've got some measure of retribution for the crime that's been committed. And the Kaiser says, well, I have a brilliant idea. I mean, he's a great ideas man, as we know. He says, given that Belgrade, as you have reminded us, Tom, channeling the Kaiser, is so close to the Austrian frontier. And Belgrade, by the way, is now partially deserted because people have fled Belgrade and the Serbians are preparing to move the government south. So the Kaiser says, well, why don't the Austrians just cross the river, go into Belgrade, occupy it peacefully?
他们对犯下的罪行进行了一定程度的报复。”德皇说：“嗯，我有个绝妙的主意。”我的意思是，如我们所知，他是个伟大的点子大王。他说：“鉴于贝尔格莱德——正如你所提醒我们的，汤姆，化身德皇——距离奥地利边境如此之近。顺便说一句，贝尔格莱德现在部分地区已经空无一人，因为人们逃离了贝尔格莱德，塞尔维亚人正准备把政府南迁。”所以德皇说：“嗯，为什么奥地利人不过河进入贝尔格莱德，和平占领它呢？
I think it's a brilliant idea. He says the Serbs are orientals and therefore deceitful and false. That's a quote. It's not brilliant idea. He says the Serbs are orientals and therefore deceitful and false. That's a quote. It's not me saying it. He says that you need a deposit, as it were. And what better than Belgrade? Yeah. I came up with this idea, didn't I?
我觉得这是个绝妙的主意。”他说塞尔维亚人是东方人，因此诡计多端、虚伪狡诈。这是一句原话。这不是绝妙的主意。他说塞尔维亚人是东方人，因此诡计多端、虚伪狡诈。这是一句原话。这不是我说的。他说你需要一个押金，类似于质押物的东西。还有什么比贝尔格莱德更好呢？是的。这个主意是我想出来的，对吧？
Did you? Yeah. When did you come up with this idea? A couple of episodes ago. I said this is a tremendous idea. This is what they should do. Just occupy Belgrade. Well, I mean, it's amazing that you and the guys have come up with exactly the same idea.
是吗？是的。你什么时候想出这个主意的？几集之前。我说过这是个绝妙的主意。这正是他们应该做的。只要占领贝尔格莱德就行。好吧，我的意思是，你和德皇想出完全一样的主意，这太神奇了。
Wow. Absolutely uncanny. And Otty in his book, July Crisis says, you know, maybe this actually wasn't such a mad idea. You know, it kind of could have worked in some way. Anyway, the trouble is, of course, the Kaiser has come up with mad ideas in the past. A podcast on Chatham High Street, invading Puerto Rico, all of these. But what if they're not mad? I mean, what if actually they're quite good ideas and the Kaiser is just surrounded by po-faced naysayers who refuse to recognize his genius, Dominic, just for the sake of argument? Yeah.
哇。简直诡异。奥特在他的《七月危机》一书中写道：“你知道，这其实也许并不是个疯狂的想法。你知道，某种程度上它可能行得通。”不管怎样，问题在于，德皇过去曾提出过疯狂的想法。在查塔姆高街搞播客、入侵波多黎各，这些全都是。但万一它们不疯狂呢？我的意思是，万一实际上它们是相当不错的主意，而德皇只是被一群刻板、满口唱反调、拒绝承认他天才的家伙包围了呢，多米尼克，为了论证起见？是的。
I mean, what if? What if, right? I mean, you might just want to stare into the mirror. Well, the thing is, I think it's fair to say that these so-called naysayers have been brutalized by ridiculous gimmicks and schemes, Tom. So, Erich von Falkenhayn, the Prussian war minister, says, yet again, he is making senseless utterances. Yeah, well, this sounds very familiar.
我的意思是，万一呢？万一呢，对吧？我的意思是，你可能只想对着镜子照一照。好吧，问题是，我认为公平地说，这些所谓的唱反调者已经被荒谬的噱头和计划给折腾得精疲力竭了，汤姆。因此，普鲁士战争大臣埃里希·冯·法金汉再次表示：“他又在发表毫无意义的言论了。”是的，好吧，这听起来太耳熟了。
That show clearly he does not want war any longer and he's quite happy to leave Austria in the lurch. You see, this is the issue. They have defined it as, we have to be a supportive, loyal friend. Our honour and prestige are bound up with this. And now for the Kaiser to say, actually, I've kind of changed my mind. Why don't the Austrians just have a little dig at Serbia and then stop? A lot of his own men say, I'm not going to sell this to the Austrians. This will annoy our only ally. So actually, they do transmit the idea, but in an incredibly vague and half-hearted way.
这清楚地表明他不再想要战争了，而且他很乐意把奥地利晾在一边。你看，这就是问题所在。他们把这定义为：我们必须是一个支持、忠诚的朋友。我们的荣誉和声望与此息息相关。而现在德皇却说：“实际上，我有点改变主意了。为什么奥地利人不稍微教训一下塞尔维亚然后就收手呢？”他自己手下的许多人说：“我可没法把这套说辞推销给奥地利人。这会惹恼我们唯一的盟友。”所以实际上，他们确实传达了这个想法，但方式极其模糊且敷衍了事。
And the Austrians just say, well, we have no interest in this. And the reason they have no interest in it is twofold. Number one, they say, this actually won't fix the problem. We'll take the city, but the Serbs will all have got away. And all of those bad guys, Apis and the Black Hand and all of those people. But they don't know about them, do they? They don't know about them, but they know there's somebody like them. They'll all be swanning around a niche in the south of Serbia and we won't have got our hands on them. Kind of communing with skulls. Right, exactly. Fondling severed breasts in briefcases and all the other stuff. Yeah, poor Balkan behavior, I think it's fair to say. And also their war plan, bizarrely, doesn't actually involve them launching a huge
而奥地利人只是说：“好吧，我们对这不感兴趣。”他们之所以不感兴趣，原因有二。第一，他们说：“这实际上无法解决问题。我们会占领这座城市，但塞尔维亚人早就全跑光了。还有那些坏蛋，阿皮斯、黑手党以及所有那些人。”但他们并不知道这些人的存在，不是吗？他们不知道具体是谁，但他们知道肯定有这样的人存在。他们全都会在塞尔维亚南部的某个隐蔽角落里逍遥自在，而我们却无法抓住他们。沉迷于与骷髅对话。没错，确切地说。在公文包里抚摸被割下来的乳房以及所有其他那些乱七八糟的东西。是的，可以公平地说，这是糟糕的巴尔干行为。而且奇怪的是，他们的战争计划实际上并不包含对贝尔格莱德发动大规模进攻。
assault on Belgrade. That's mad. Why not? They want to bypass the capital and they want to wipe out the Serbian army. That's what General Conrad wants to do. He wants to invade from the west. So actually they say, let's just ignore the Kaiser. Tom, is this at all familiar? It is. Let's just pretend this never happened and he'll forget about it and move on to something else. Yeah.
太疯狂了。为什么不呢？他们想绕过首都，歼灭塞尔维亚军队。这就是康拉德将军想做的事。他想从西面进攻。所以实际上他们说：“咱们别理德皇了。”汤姆，这熟悉吗？熟悉。咱们就当这事儿从没发生过，他自己就会忘掉，然后去关注别的事情了。是的。
All these WhatsApp messages I never see. Yeah. Now, meanwhile, some of the Kaiser's generals are now actively preparing for war. And this is a chance to bring on stage another slightly bizarre character, who is the German chief of staff, the man in charge of the war plans, who at this very moment, while the Kaiser is going around telling everybody about his brilliant scheme, this guy, Helmut Moltke the Younger, is writing his big report on the military situation, how they're going to deal with it. And everybody in this story has kind of demons, skeletons in their closet, shadows. Melancholia.
所有这些我从不看的WhatsApp消息。是的。与此同时，德皇的一些将军们现在正积极备战。这是一个将另一个略显古怪的人物请上台的机会，他就是德国总参谋长、负责战争计划的人。就在此时此刻，当德皇四处向所有人兜售他那绝妙的计划时，这家伙——小毛奇——正在撰写关于军事形势的大报告，讲述他们将如何应对。这个故事里的每个人都有某种心魔、内心的秘密骷髅、阴影。忧郁症。
Yeah, melancholia. So Helmut Moltke the Younger, his uncle was the guy who'd won the Franco-Prussian War. And he lives in the shadow of his uncle. And everybody basically all his life has said, he's all right, but he's not as good as his uncle. And he's had to live with that. He's also, he's a cellist. Well, he's German, so he's bound to play a musical instrument. He's very melancholy. He's a Christian scientist. I don't actually really know what a Christian scientist is, but he also very keen on the occult and spiritualism. So he's a huge admirer of someone called Madame Blavatsky. Are you familiar with her work? Yeah, I am. Theosophy. Yeah, theosophy.
是的，忧郁症。所以小毛奇，他的叔叔就是赢得普法战争的那个人。他生活在他叔叔的阴影之下。他这辈子基本上所有人都对他说：“他还可以，但他不如他叔叔。”他不得不忍受这一点。他还是个大提琴手。好吧，他是德国人，所以他必然会演奏某种乐器。他非常忧郁。他是基督教科学派信徒。我其实并不真正知道基督教科学派是什么，但他同时也极其热衷于神秘主义和灵媒。所以他是某个叫海莲娜·布拉瓦茨基的人的超级崇拜者。你熟悉她的著作吗？是的，我很熟悉。神智学。是的，神智学。
So he believes in reincarnation. But all of this means that Moltke is incredibly pessimistic and fatalistic. He sort of thinks whatever will happen will happen. It'll all end in tears and disaster. Right. So we were talking about how kind of the bellicosity, such as it was of the German high command, is interfused with a sense of bleakness yes that it will all be for nothing and that germany is doomed yeah and i guess he's he's
所以他相信轮回转世。但所有这一切意味着毛奇极其悲观且宿命论。他有点认为该发生的事总会发生。一切都会以眼泪和灾难告终。没错。所以我们刚才在谈论，德国最高指挥部的这种好战情绪（如果算得上的话）是如何与一种阴冷晦暗的感觉交织在一起的——是的，一切都将付诸东流，德国已经注定了。是的，我想他就是这种情绪的化身，不是吗？所以毛奇，如果你还记得的话，他去过矿泉疗养地——这对于治病可没好处——去波西米亚的日耳曼温泉泡温泉。所以过去三个星期他基本上一直在喝硫磺水，或者你在那里做的那些事——我想你得扔实心球，
the kind of embodiment of it isn't he really so moltker if you remember he's been to spa town which is not good for you taking the water as a germanic spa in bohemia so he's been basically drinking sulfur or whatever you do for the last three weeks i think you throw medicine balls yeah and just eating like pieces of celery so that hasn't added to his general jollity one jot and all that sulfur in the water yeah not good for the bowels precisely so he's been going around for years saying you know we'll have to fight the russians one day the sooner the better if we wait any longer we'll be absolutely crushed. And right now, he says, this whole crisis has been engineered by the French and the Russians. Clearly, they encircle us. They're about to attack us. We should make preparations right away,
然后只吃芹菜之类的东西。这可一点也没有给他的总体快乐心情添砖加瓦。水里有那么多硫磺，是的，对肠胃可真不好，确切地说。所以他多年来一直到处说：“我们总有一天得跟俄国人打一仗，越早越好。如果我们再等下去，就会被彻底碾碎。”而现在，他说：“这场危机是由法国人和俄国人精心策划的。很显然，他们包围了我们。他们随时准备进攻我们。我们应该立刻做好准备，翻出我们向西进攻的计划，所有这些。”然而，非同寻常的是，即使在这份备忘录里，他在最后也说道：“我们应该为冲突做准备。这是不可避免的。它将消灭整个欧洲的文明。但是，话说回来，管他呢，干吧！”是的。好吧，我们必须开战，因为如果我们不打，我们就会从地图上被抹去。这是一种奇怪的、宿命论的好战情绪，不是吗？
dig out our plan to strike West, all of this stuff. And yet, the extraordinary thing is, even in this memo, he says at the end, we should prepare for the conflict. It's inevitable. And it will annihilate the civilization of all Europe. But, you know, why not? Whatever, let's go for it. Yeah. Well, we have to go for it because if we don't, we will be wiped from the map. It's a strange, fatalistic bellicosity, isn't it?
是的。我想他们把自己看作几乎是瓦格纳式的英雄，你知道的，比如《诸神的黄昏》什么的。他们将在烈火中毁灭，但至少他们能战死沙场。人们会为他们歌唱。没错。在未来的岁月里。没错。
Yeah. I think they see themselves as almost like Wagnerian heroes, you know, Gutter Dammerung or something. They will be consumed by fire, but at least they can die sword in hand. Songs will be sung of them. Right. In ages to come. Exactly.
没错。这就是柏林正在发生的事情。但实际上，有趣的是，毛奇和战争大臣法金汉现在就想进行军事准备。但宰相特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格说不。文官们依然掌权。
Exactly. So this is what's going on in Berlin. But actually, interestingly, Moltke and the war minister Falkenhayn want to have military preparations right now. But the chancellor, Tebald Bethmann-Holweg, says no. The civilians are still in charge.
所以，有些人认为德国名义上是个军事独裁国家，其实并非如此，这种说法并不准确。文官们依然在掌权，他们说：“我们不想惊动俄罗斯，所以我们不会动员，现在还不会做任何类似的事情。”与此同时，奥地利人终于（难以置信地）把行动统一起来了。现在是7月28日星期二，正好是弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲遇刺一个月。弗朗茨·约瑟夫在巴德伊舍的书房里，用一支羽毛笔——一支鸵鸟羽毛笔——签署了对塞尔维亚的宣战书。像所有人一样，这定下了基调。他的宣言是用十种不同的语言发布的，因为这毕竟是一个多语言、多民族的帝国。他说：“我们被迫拔剑。我们本不想这样做，但我们被一个充满仇恨的敌人包围了。我们以极其不情愿的心情这样做，但这已经是我们唯一的出路。”防御性侵略。
So it's not quite true, as some people think, that Germany is effectively a military dictatorship in all but name. That's not right. The civilians are still in charge, and they say, we do not want to alarm Russia, so we won't mobilize, we won't do any of that just yet. Meanwhile, the Austrians have finally, unbelievably, got their act together. So it's now Tuesday, the 28th of July, exactly a month since the murder of Franz Ferdinand and Sophie. Franz Joseph signs the declaration of war on Serbia with a quill pen, an ostrich feather quill in his study at Bad Ischl. Like everybody, this sets the tone, his proclamation, which is in 10 different languages, because of course,
防御性侵略，没错。现在，令人难以置信的是，直到这个时候，在他们付诸行动、在他们宣战之后，外交大臣贝希多尔德才对康拉德将军说：“顺便检查一下，如果俄罗斯人真的进行干预的话——我刚刚才想到，实际上这是一种完全可能的假设——你对此制定过计划吗？我的意思是，你们进行过兵棋推演吧？我们确实有足够的军队来对付塞尔维亚并守住东线。”而康拉德则回答：“现在才来问我这个，未免太晚了吧，因为答案是没有，我们并没有。”于是贝希多尔德说：“哦，好吧，我想一切都会没事的。我会告诉我们的大使使用坚决的语言来威慑俄国人。所以我想一切都会好起来的。”如果我们把故事在这一刻定格——7月28日，有哪些可能的结局呢？一种可能性当然是，宣战之后，奥地利人却什么都不做。这有点像德皇式的设想。或者他们可能只是通过桥梁跨过河进入贝尔格莱德然后就停下。
a multilingual, multi-ethnic empire. And he says, we have been forced to draw the sword. We didn't want to, but we're surrounded by an enemy filled with hatred. And we're doing this with great reluctance, but it's our only course. Defensive aggression. Defensive aggression, exactly. Now, unbelievably, it's only at this point, after they've done it, after they've declared war that count bergatol the foreign minister says to general conrad just to check if the russians do intervene it's only just occurred to me actually that that's a plausible possibility you have got plans for
这就是我的计划。我当时就会这么做。那是你的计划。当然，他们才不想那样做。当他们字面意义上、实实在在地为了连根拔起恐怖分子而做好了准备时，他们会觉得那样做既屈辱又诡异。这就像9·11之后的美国在阿富汗一样。
that i mean you've war-gamed it right we do have enough troops to deal with serbia and hold the eastern frontier and conrad well, it's rather late to be asking me that now, because the answer is no, they don't. And so Bertolt says, oh, well, I'm sure it'll be fine, actually. I'll tell our ambassador to use decided language to deter the Russians. So I'm sure it'll be OK. So if we just stop the story at this point, 28th of July, what are the plausible outcomes? So one possibility, of course, is having declared war, the Austrians then don't do anything. This is a kind of slightly Kaiser scenario. Or maybe they just go into Belgrade across the bridge or bridges and then stop.
如果你抓不到恐怖分子，那一开始搞这一出还有什么意义？所以这是第一种选择。第二种选择是奥地利人发动进攻，而奇迹般地，俄罗斯人没有进行干预。也就是俄罗斯人退缩了。我们已经描述过这种情况有多么不可能，我们将看到俄罗斯人实际上会如何反应。当然，第三种选择就是世界大战。即使在此时此刻，我认为世界大战的选项也是所有可能选项中可能性最大的一项。因为就在那天下午，在奥地利对圣彼得堡宣战后，我们在两集前谈到的几个人——俄罗斯外交大臣谢尔盖·萨扎诺夫，以及那个荒谬的法国大使莫里斯·帕莱洛格（就是那个写假报告的家伙——
That's my plan. That's what I would have done. That's your plan. Of course, they don't want to do that. They think that would be humiliating and weird when they've been gearing up, as it were, literally, to root out the terrorists. That's what they're doing. It's like America in Afghanistan after 9-11.
是的，在还没见到沙皇之前，就写好了他与沙皇会面的虚构记述。）他们见面并说道：“在这个问题上我们绝不退缩。强硬是这些奥地利人唯一能听懂的语言。我们不能退缩。”于是，外交大臣萨扎诺夫前往彼得宫（沙皇的宫殿），他对沙皇说：“您已经签署了一项命令，动员了四个西部军区——敖德萨、基辅、莫斯科和喀山。
If you don't get the terrorists, what was the point in doing it in the first place? So that's option number one. Option number two is the Austrians do attack, and miraculously, the Russians don't intervene. So the Russians do back down. And we have already described how unlikely that is, and we will see how the Russians do respond. And of course, option number three is a world war. And even at this point, I think a world war option is by far the most likely of the possible options. Because that very afternoon, after the Austrian declaration of war in St. Petersburg, a couple of people who we talked about two episodes ago, the Russian
现在我希望您能原则上同意签署一项命令，对我们的军队进行总动员。换句话说，让他们上火车，开始向边境移动，做好所有军事准备，因为如果我们不这样做，而同盟国——德国和奥地利率先发动攻击，那就太迟了。”换句话说，我们必须抢先一步，然后马上行动起来。他们不得不这样做，因为俄罗斯的规模显然要大得多。它体量庞大且行动迟缓。他们说：“我们要么启动这两个命令中的一个，要么仅仅动员四个……”
foreign minister, Sergei Sazonov, and the ludicrous French ambassador, Maurice Paliolog, the guy who writes fake reports. Yeah, the fictionalized accounts of his meeting with the Tsar before he's actually met the Tsar. Yes. They meet and they say, you know, we're not going to back down on this. Strength is the only language that these Austrians understand. We can't back down. And so Sazanov, the foreign minister, goes to the Peterhof Palace, the Tsar's Palace, and he says, you've already signed an order to mobilize the four Western military districts, Odessa, Kiev, Moscow, and Kazan.
外长谢尔盖·萨佐诺夫，还有那个荒唐的法国大使莫里斯·帕列奥洛グ——就是那个写假报告的家伙。是的，那些关于他在实际见到沙皇之前就与沙皇会面的虚构记述。是的。他们会面并表示，你知道的，我们在这个问题上不会退缩。实力是这些奥地利人唯一能听懂的语言。我们不能退缩。因此，外长萨佐诺夫前往彼得霍夫宫，即沙皇的宫殿，他说，您已经签署了一项命令，动员四个西部军区，即敖德萨、基辅、莫斯科和喀山。
Now I would like you to agree to sign an order, in principle, for general mobilization of our armies. In other words, get them onto the railways, start moving them towards the frontier, all military preparations, because if we don't and the central powers, Germany and Austria strike first, it will be too late. So in other words, we have to steal a march and then we have to get going now. And they have to do that because Russia obviously is so much larger. It's large and slow. And they say, we will put one of these two orders into operation, either just the four
现在我希望您原则上同意签署一项关于我们军队进行总动员的命令。换句话说，让他们上铁路，开始向边境移动，做好所有军事准备，因为如果我们不这样做，而同盟国——德国和奥地利率先发动进攻，那就太晚了。换句话说，我们必须抢先一步，然后现在就行动起来。他们必须这样做，因为俄罗斯显然要庞大得多。它体量庞大且行动迟缓。他们说，我们将实施这两道命令中的其中一道，要么仅仅是那四个
districts or the whole Russian empire. And basically the decision is which we do. So the option of doing nothing is not on the table. No, there's no question of doing nothing. And Nicholas, as he goes to bed that night, he has that choice hanging over him. We can just do a partial mobilization, which would just be sending a signal to the Austrians And Nicholas, as he goes to bed that night, he has that choice hanging over him. We can just do a partial mobilization, which would just be sending a signal to the Austrians and the Germans, or general, which is kind of, I mean, it's more than a signal. That is basically taking a very big step towards war.
districts or the whole Russian empire. And basically the decision is which we do. So the option of doing nothing is not on the table. No, there's no question of doing nothing. And Nicholas, as he goes to bed that night, he has that choice hanging over him. We can just do a partial mobilization, which would just be sending a signal to the Austrians And Nicholas, as he goes to bed that night, he has that choice hanging over him. We can just do a partial mobilization, which would just be sending a signal to the Austrians and the Germans, or general, which is kind of, I mean, it's more than a signal. That is basically taking a very big step towards war.|||地区，或者是整个俄罗斯帝国。基本上，决定就是我们该选哪一个。所以，什么都不做的选项是不存在的。不，根本不存在什么都不做什么的问题。尼古拉那天晚上上床睡觉时，那个选择一直悬在他的心头。我们可以只进行局部总动员，这只是向奥地利人和尼古拉那天晚上上床睡觉时，那个选择一直悬在他的心头。我们可以只进行局部总动员，这只是向奥地利人和德国人发出一个信号，或者进行总动员——这某种程度上，我的意思是，这不仅仅是一个信号。这基本上是向战争迈出了非常大的一步。
So he goes to bed that night, Tuesday the 28th. Then in the early hours, Wednesday the 29th, just after midnight, suddenly there was this massive explosion outside Belgrade. And what has happened is a group of Serbians under a character from our Sarajevo series, Major Vojislav Tankovic, so one of these key figures in grooming and arming the killers, Princip and his gang, they blow up the railway bridge, which is the crucial link between Belgrade and Austria-Hungary. So there's this huge explosion that is kind of reverberating around Belgrade. And then shortly afterwards, three Austro-Hungarian river warships come into view through the darkness. And they are at the point where the Sava meets the Danube, right opposite this great stronghold,
So he goes to bed that night, Tuesday the 28th. Then in the early hours, Wednesday the 29th, just after midnight, suddenly there was this massive explosion outside Belgrade. And what has happened is a group of Serbians under a character from our Sarajevo series, Major Vojislav Tankovic, so one of these key figures in grooming and arming the killers, Princip and his gang, they blow up the railway bridge, which is the crucial link between Belgrade and Austria-Hungary. So there's this huge explosion that is kind of reverberating around Belgrade. And then shortly afterwards, three Austro-Hungarian river warships come into view through the darkness. And they are at the point where the Sava meets the Danube, right opposite this great stronghold,|||于是他在那天晚上（28日星期二）上床睡觉了。接着在29日星期三的清晨，刚过午夜不久，贝尔格莱德郊外突然发生了一声巨大的爆炸。发生的事情是，一群塞尔维亚人在我们萨拉热窝系列节目中出现过的人物——少校沃伊斯拉夫·坦科维奇（Vojislav Tankovic）的带领下——也就是培养和武装刺客普林西普及其同伙的关键人物之一——炸毁了铁桥，这是贝尔格莱德和奥匈帝国之间的关键纽带。因此，一声巨大的爆炸在贝尔格莱德周围回荡。紧接着，三艘奥匈帝国江防炮舰在黑暗中出现在视野中。它们位于萨瓦河与多瑙河交汇处，正对着这座宏伟的据点，
the Kalamegdan Citadel that overshadows Belgrade. And it's at two o'clock that morning that a warship with the splendid name of the Bodrog, the Bodrog, opens fire on the citadel and on the Serbian positions on the south bank. So these are the shots that are designed as revenge for Franz Ferdinand and his wife Sophie. But these are also, of course, the shots that effectively open the First World War. Well, on that note, the tension is so great that I think we need a break. We'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde.
the Kalamegdan Citadel that overshadows Belgrade. And it's at two o'clock that morning that a warship with the splendid name of the Bodrog, the Bodrog, opens fire on the citadel and on the Serbian positions on the south bank. So these are the shots that are designed as revenge for Franz Ferdinand and his wife Sophie. But these are also, of course, the shots that effectively open the First World War. Well, on that note, the tension is so great that I think we need a break. We'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde.|||俯瞰着贝尔格莱德的卡莱梅格丹城堡。就在那天早晨两点钟，一艘拥有一个响亮名字的军舰——“博德罗格”号（Bodrog），向城堡以及南岸的塞尔维亚人阵地开火了。因此，这些炮弹旨在为弗朗茨·斐迪南大公和他的妻子索菲复仇。但当然，这也是实际上拉开第一次世界大战序幕的枪声。好吧，说到这里，气氛如此紧张，我认为我们需要休息一下。我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,|||我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《剩下的都是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and welcome to what I think is the most dramatic day of the building crisis so far, isn't it? Shots have been fired. I guess the First World War has begun. But as yet, it's Austria on Serbia. None of the other great powers have yet been drawn into the conflict, but things are looking bad. Though not in Vienna, where people have poured out onto the street in celebration when they've heard the news. There's a big parade of veterans associations. There are about a hundred thousand people on the streets of Vienna, most of them young men, it has to be said. Although we get a brilliant insight into how ordinary Viennese, you know, not necessarily very bellicose people thought about this, from of all people, Sigmund Freud.
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and welcome to what I think is the most dramatic day of the building crisis so far, isn't it? Shots have been fired. I guess the First World War has begun. But as yet, it's Austria on Serbia. None of the other great powers have yet been drawn into the conflict, but things are looking bad. Though not in Vienna, where people have poured out onto the street in celebration when they've heard the news. There's a big parade of veterans associations. There are about a hundred thousand people on the streets of Vienna, most of them young men, it has to be said. Although we get a brilliant insight into how ordinary Viennese, you know, not necessarily very bellicose people thought about this, from of all people, Sigmund Freud.|||请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的轨迹》（The Rest Is History），欢迎来到我认为迄今为止这场蓄积中的危机中最戏剧性的一天，对吧？枪声已经打响。我想第一次世界大战已经开始了。但到目前为止，这是奥地利对塞尔维亚的战争。其他大国尚未被卷入冲突，但情况看起来很不妙。不过维也纳并非如此，人们听到消息后涌上街头庆祝。这里有一场老兵协会的大游行。维也纳街头大约有十万人，必须承认，其中大部分是年轻男子。尽管我们从一个意想不到的人——西格蒙德·弗洛伊德（Sigmund Freud）那里，对普通维也纳人（你知道的，并非都是那么好战的人）是如何看待这件事的，有了深刻的了解。
So Freud wrote that day, for the first time in 30 years, I feel myself to be an Austrian and I feel like giving this not very hopeful empire another chance. And then the very peculiar line, all my libido is dedicated to Austria-Hung i can only say lucky austria hungary so they may have a slightly disorganized army and a dithering high command but they've got freud's libido on their side so it's all looking good that same morning wednesday the 29th where freud is thinking about his libido the british cabinet is meeting again to discuss this and sir edward gray your man tom takes the lead. He is working for peace, Dominic. Well, he has been working for peace, yes.
So Freud wrote that day, for the first time in 30 years, I feel myself to be an Austrian and I feel like giving this not very hopeful empire another chance. And then the very peculiar line, all my libido is dedicated to Austria-Hung i can only say lucky austria hungary so they may have a slightly disorganized army and a dithering high command but they've got freud's libido on their side so it's all looking good that same morning wednesday the 29th where freud is thinking about his libido the british cabinet is meeting again to discuss this and sir edward gray your man tom takes the lead. He is working for peace, Dominic. Well, he has been working for peace, yes.|||于是弗洛伊德那天写道：“30年来第一次，我觉得自己是一个奥地利人，我觉得应该给这个不怎么有希望的帝国一次机会。”接着是一句非常奇特的话：“我所有的力比多（libido）都献给了奥匈帝国——我只能说，幸运的奥匈帝国。”所以他们可能有一支略显混乱的军队和一个优柔寡断的高层指挥部，但他们有弗洛伊德的力比多站在他们一边，所以一切看起来都不错。就在那个早晨，29日星期三，当弗洛伊德在思考他的力比多时，英国内阁再次开会讨论此事，而你的人、汤姆，爱德华·格雷爵士（Sir Edward Grey）带头了。他在为和平而努力，多米尼克。嗯，他一直都在为和平努力，是的。
Yeah. He's very quiet and he's very serious. And he says, listen, with that news from Belgrade, stakes are really high now. There is a massive chance now that all Europe will be at war. And then, frankly, we will have a decision to make. And this is the first time that they discuss a country that we have not really mentioned at all in this series or perhaps just in passing once or twice
Yeah. He's very quiet and he's very serious. And he says, listen, with that news from Belgrade, stakes are really high now. There is a massive chance now that all Europe will be at war. And then, frankly, we will have a decision to make. And this is the first time that they discuss a country that we have not really mentioned at all in this series or perhaps just in passing once or twice|||是的。他非常安静，也非常严肃。他说：“听着，随着贝尔格莱德传来的这个消息，现在的赌注非常之高。现在全欧洲陷入战争的可能性极大。然后，坦率地说，我们将不得不做出决定。”这是他们第一次讨论一个我们在本系列中几乎完全没有提到过、或者可能只是顺带提过一两次的国家，
and that is of course Belgium or as we should probably say plucky little Belgium plucky little Belgium with its empire in the Congo that little bit at the end of the sentence is the bit that everybody misses off it is but for now we're sticking with plucky little Belgium. So Gray hands around papers that he's prepared on two treaties that were signed in 1839 and 1870. And he says, listen, this is why Belgium is an issue. So these treaties guaranteed Belgium's independence. And he says, look, everybody knows it is common knowledge in Europe that the Germans will go west first if there's a war.
and that is of course Belgium or as we should probably say plucky little Belgium plucky little Belgium with its empire in the Congo that little bit at the end of the sentence is the bit that everybody misses off it is but for now we're sticking with plucky little Belgium. So Gray hands around papers that he's prepared on two treaties that were signed in 1839 and 1870. And he says, listen, this is why Belgium is an issue. So these treaties guaranteed Belgium's independence. And he says, look, everybody knows it is common knowledge in Europe that the Germans will go west first if there's a war.|||那个国家当然就是比利时，或者正如我们可能应该说的，勇敢的小比利时。勇敢的小比利时，它在刚果还拥有帝国——句子末尾的那一小部分是每个人都会漏掉的，确实如此，但目前我们还是叫它勇敢的小比利时吧。因此，格雷分发了他准备的关于1839年和1870年签署的两份条约的文件。他说：“听着，这就是为什么比利时是一个问题。因此，这些条约保证了比利时的独立。”他说：“看，每个人都知道，欧洲人尽皆知的是，如果发生战争，德国人首先会向西进发。”
They will strike at France because the French are their most dangerous enemies. And then they will turn back to deal with Russia. This is the so-called Schlieffen Plan, which historians now argue about whether it existed or not. Yeah, the sleeve of the German brushing the channel. Exactly. Exactly. Now, they could go slightly further south in the sort of what were once Alsace and Lorraine that have been taken from France. However, the French
They will strike at France because the French are their most dangerous enemies. And then they will turn back to deal with Russia. This is the so-called Schlieffen Plan, which historians now argue about whether it existed or not. Yeah, the sleeve of the German brushing the channel. Exactly. Exactly. Now, they could go slightly further south in the sort of what were once Alsace and Lorraine that have been taken from France. However, the French|||他们会打击法国，因为法国人是他们最危险的敌人。然后他们会回过头来对付俄国。这就是所谓的“施利芬计划”，历史学家现在还在争论这个计划是否真的存在过。对，德国人的衣袖擦过海峡。没错。没错。现在，他们可以向南一点，进入曾被从法国夺走的阿尔萨斯和洛林地区。然而，法国人
have got massive forts there. It's fortified citadels of Verdun at Nancy, at Belfort and all these places. You'd be mad to attack there. You just can't attack there. So that leaves the Germans with only one option, which is to attack further north through Luxembourg and Belgium. So Belgium, Belgium has only existed as a country since 1830. And it was sponsored by Britain, basically. It broke away from the Netherlands because it was Catholic and the Netherlands was Protestant. Britain was its big patron and sponsor because it wanted to buff a state against France in those days. And so it's a kind of guarantor. Yeah. Britain is a guarantor. So in 1839, all the great powers had signed a treaty. They'd all signed, not just Britain,
have got massive forts there. It's fortified citadels of Verdun at Nancy, at Belfort and all these places. You'd be mad to attack there. You just can't attack there. So that leaves the Germans with only one option, which is to attack further north through Luxembourg and Belgium. So Belgium, Belgium has only existed as a country since 1830. And it was sponsored by Britain, basically. It broke away from the Netherlands because it was Catholic and the Netherlands was Protestant. Britain was its big patron and sponsor because it wanted to buff a state against France in those days. And so it's a kind of guarantor. Yeah. Britain is a guarantor. So in 1839, all the great powers had signed a treaty. They'd all signed, not just Britain,|||在那里拥有庞大的要塞。那是凡尔登、南锡、贝尔福以及所有这些地方的加固城堡。去那里进攻简直是疯了。你根本无法在那里进攻。因此，这给德国人只留下了一个选择，那就是向北穿过卢森堡和比利时发动进攻。所以比利时，比利时作为一个国家只存在于1830年以后。它基本上是由英国资助的。它从荷兰分裂出去，因为它是天主教国家，而荷兰是新教国家。英国是它的主要庇护人和赞助者，因为当时英国想要建立一个对抗法国的缓冲区。所以它是一种担保人。是的。英国是担保人。因此在1839年，所有大国都签署了一项条约。他们都签署了，不仅仅是英国，
the Prussians, for example, a commitment that was inherited by Germany. And then in 1839, all the great powers had signed a treaty. They'd all signed, not just Britain, the Prussians, for example, a commitment that was inherited by Germany. And then in 1870, in the Franco-Prussian War, France and Prussia had agreed that they would both respect Belgian neutrality as long as the other one did as well. And they'd signed those treaties with Britain. So Gray says, listen, under these treaties, if the Germans do go through Belgium and if the Belgians appeal for help, we will be legally bound, legally obliged to help them.
the Prussians, for example, a commitment that was inherited by Germany. And then in 1839, all the great powers had signed a treaty. They'd all signed, not just Britain, the Prussians, for example, a commitment that was inherited by Germany. And then in 1870, in the Franco-Prussian War, France and Prussia had agreed that they would both respect Belgian neutrality as long as the other one did as well. And they'd signed those treaties with Britain. So Gray says, listen, under these treaties, if the Germans do go through Belgium and if the Belgians appeal for help, we will be legally bound, legally obliged to help them.|||例如普鲁士人，这项承诺后来由德国继承。然后，在1839年，所有大国都签署了一项条约。他们都签署了，不仅是英国，例如普鲁士人，这项承诺由德国继承。接着在1870年的普法战争中，法国和普鲁士曾同意，只要对方也这样做，他们双方都会尊重比利时的中立。他们与英国签署了这些条约。因此格雷说：“听着，根据这些条约，如果德国人确实穿过了比利时，并且如果比利时人呼吁援助，我们在法律上有约束力、在法律上有义务去帮助他们。”
But in the same way that America and Britain are legally obliged to help Ukraine after signing that treaty. Yeah. To respect their independence and all the rest of it. Yes. But we got out of that. Yeah. We're not legally obliged to fight. So here's the thing. It's very clear, says Gray from our lawyers, that that help could
But in the same way that America and Britain are legally obliged to help Ukraine after signing that treaty. Yeah. To respect their independence and all the rest of it. Yes. But we got out of that. Yeah. We're not legally obliged to fight. So here's the thing. It's very clear, says Gray from our lawyers, that that help could|||就像美国和英国在签署该条约后在法律上有义务帮助乌克兰一样。是的。去尊重他们的独立等等。是的。但我们摆脱了那个。是的。我们在法律上没有义务去战斗。所以问题是这样的。格雷根据我们的律师的话说，很明显，这种帮助可以
just be diplomatic, especially if the Belgians don't fight themselves. So if the Belgians just want us to kind of go to, I don't know, arbitration, sanctions. Yeah. Send a sternly phrased telegram. Yeah. To voice our enduring love of Belgium, Freight, whatever it might be. We could just do that. We have the option. He says it's a matter of policy rather than of legal obligation. And even Churchill accepts that. Everybody accepts that. They literally get out the map. And they get out the map on the table. David Lloyd George, the chancellor, says, look here, probably the Germans are only going to go through the southern bit of Belgium. And in that case, everybody says, man, that case is a bit much to go to war about that, isn't it? And actually,
just be diplomatic, especially if the Belgians don't fight themselves. So if the Belgians just want us to kind of go to, I don't know, arbitration, sanctions. Yeah. Send a sternly phrased telegram. Yeah. To voice our enduring love of Belgium, Freight, whatever it might be. We could just do that. We have the option. He says it's a matter of policy rather than of legal obligation. And even Churchill accepts that. Everybody accepts that. They literally get out the map. And they get out the map on the table. David Lloyd George, the chancellor, says, look here, probably the Germans are only going to go through the southern bit of Belgium. And in that case, everybody says, man, that case is a bit much to go to war about that, isn't it? And actually,|||仅仅是外交上的，特别是如果比利时人自己不战斗的话。因此，如果比利时人只是想让我们去进行，我不知道，仲裁、制裁。是的。发一份措辞严厉的电报。是的。为了表达我们对比利时持久的爱，货运，无论可能是什么。我们完全可以做到这一点。我们有这个选择。他说这是一个政策问题，而不是法律义务问题。甚至丘吉尔也接受这一点。每个人都接受这一点。他们真的把地图拿出来了。他们把地图摊在桌子上。财政大臣大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）说：“看这里，可能德国人只会穿过比利时的南部。在这种情况下，”每个人都说，“天哪，为了那个去打仗未免有点过头了吧，不是吗？”事实上，
even Churchill. So Churchill has been going around like a firework about to go off, isn't he, this week? He keeps going around saying, I've never been happier. War is coming. Yeah, well, he has this brilliant letter that he writes to Clemmie, his wife, where he says, everything tends towards catastrophe and collapse. I am interested, geared up and happy. But even Churchill, you see, who's gagging for war because he just loves wars, says, I don't see why we should come in if they go only a little way into Belgium. And the reason they're saying that is Churchill also says war would be a calamity for the civilized nations. So they know, they absolutely know that great war will be a nightmare and they're keen to avoid it and they are hoping that they can get out of doing it so the cabinet meeting breaks up there's no
even Churchill. So Churchill has been going around like a firework about to go off, isn't he, this week? He keeps going around saying, I've never been happier. War is coming. Yeah, well, he has this brilliant letter that he writes to Clemmie, his wife, where he says, everything tends towards catastrophe and collapse. I am interested, geared up and happy. But even Churchill, you see, who's gagging for war because he just loves wars, says, I don't see why we should come in if they go only a little way into Belgium. And the reason they're saying that is Churchill also says war would be a calamity for the civilized nations. So they know, they absolutely know that great war will be a nightmare and they're keen to avoid it and they are hoping that they can get out of doing it so the cabinet meeting breaks up there's no|||甚至连丘吉尔也是如此。所以丘吉尔这周一直像个随时会爆炸的爆竹一样到处乱跑，不是吗？他一直在到处说：“我从来没有这么高兴过。战争要来了。”是的，好吧，他给他妻子克莱米（Clemmie）写了一封精彩绝伦的信，他在信中说：“一切都朝着灾难和崩溃的方向发展。我很感兴趣，斗志昂扬，而且很高兴。”但你看，即使是渴望战争、因为他就是热爱战争的丘吉尔，也说道：“如果他们只是深入比利时一点点，我看不出我们有什么理由卷入其中。”他们之所以这么说，是因为丘吉尔也说过，对于文明国家来说，战争将是一场灾难。所以他们知道，他们非常清楚，大战将是一场噩梦，他们渴望避免它，并且他们希望能够抽身不干，因此内阁会议解散了，没有
decision being made grey goes off and he meets a group of liberal backbenchers and they say could you go public because you say britain will stay out because that might discourage the French and the Russians. And he says, no, I can't do that. I must be ambiguous. I need a free hand. I don't want to be tied down because that might encourage the Germans. But I think you could say as a criticism of Gray that by this point, he's running out of time with his ambiguity. And actually, of course, all the time he has promised the French. He has subcontracted his decision-making to the French because he has promised them, when it does come to the crunch, we will be there. And I think as much as you admire Gray, Tom, I think he is being a little bit disingenuous
decision being made grey goes off and he meets a group of liberal backbenchers and they say could you go public because you say britain will stay out because that might discourage the French and the Russians. And he says, no, I can't do that. I must be ambiguous. I need a free hand. I don't want to be tied down because that might encourage the Germans. But I think you could say as a criticism of Gray that by this point, he's running out of time with his ambiguity. And actually, of course, all the time he has promised the French. He has subcontracted his decision-making to the French because he has promised them, when it does come to the crunch, we will be there. And I think as much as you admire Gray, Tom, I think he is being a little bit disingenuous|||做出任何决定。格雷离开后，他会见了 一群自由党后座议员，他们说：“你能公开表态吗？因为你说英国会置身事外，这可能会打消法国人和俄国人的念头。”他说：“不，我不能这么做。我必须保持模棱两可。我需要自由行事。我不想被束缚手脚，因为那可能会鼓励德国人。”但我想你可以把这一点作为对格雷的批评：到目前为止，他的这种模棱两可已经快要用尽时间了。事实上，当然，他一直向法国人承诺。他把自己的决策权外包给了法国人，因为他向他们承诺过，当真正到紧要关头时，我们会出现的。汤姆，尽管你很钦佩格雷，但我认为他在这一点上有点不够坦诚，
with his own colleagues. So this is the criticism in Neil Ferguson's book, The Pity of War, isn't it? Yes. I mean, this is the case he makes against Gray and says that Gray's ambiguity encouraged the other powers to go to war and then left Britain powerless to avoid being drawn into the meat grinder itself and should have stayed out. I think you can make the case that Gray's ambiguity, I mean, it obviously doesn't work because Britain is drawn into the war and the war happens, but you can understand why he's ambiguous. And the other
with his own colleagues. So this is the criticism in Neil Ferguson's book, The Pity of War, isn't it? Yes. I mean, this is the case he makes against Gray and says that Gray's ambiguity encouraged the other powers to go to war and then left Britain powerless to avoid being drawn into the meat grinder itself and should have stayed out. I think you can make the case that Gray's ambiguity, I mean, it obviously doesn't work because Britain is drawn into the war and the war happens, but you can understand why he's ambiguous. And the other|||对他的同僚们有所保留。所以这就是尼尔·弗格森（Neil Ferguson）的书《战争的悲剧》（The Pity of War）中的批评，对吧？是的。我的意思是，这就是他针对格雷提出的论点，他说格雷的模棱两可鼓励了其他大国发动战争，然后让英国无力避免自身被卷入绞肉机，本该置身事外的。我认为你可以这样认为，格雷的模棱两可——我的意思是，它显然没有起作用，因为英国被卷入了战争，战争爆发了——但你能理解他为什么会模棱两可。另一个
thing I think about the criticism of Gray, actually, having made that criticism about the ambiguity, I think people have a tendency to assume that rather like now, when something happens, everyone blames the Americans, even if the Americans don't really control it at all. They say, well, the Americans should have stopped it. The American Secretary of State was asleep. American Secretary of State should have sorted all this out. But sometimes it's just not the big powers. It's not in their power. You know, Gray did all that he could. Well, I think also because he has access to all the telegrams and papers and he's the one who's focusing on it even more than anyone else in cabinet, he is thinking it cannot be possible that we go to war over this. Our interests are
thing I think about the criticism of Gray, actually, having made that criticism about the ambiguity, I think people have a tendency to assume that rather like now, when something happens, everyone blames the Americans, even if the Americans don't really control it at all. They say, well, the Americans should have stopped it. The American Secretary of State was asleep. American Secretary of State should have sorted all this out. But sometimes it's just not the big powers. It's not in their power. You know, gray did all that he could. Well, I think also because he has access to all the telegrams and papers and he's the one who's focusing on it even more than anyone else in cabinet, he is thinking it cannot be possible that we go to war over this. Our interests are|||我认为关于对格雷的批评，其实，在提出了关于模棱两可的批评之后，人们往往会有一种倾向，那就是像现在一样，当发生什么事情时，每个人都把责任怪到美国人头上，即使美国人根本无法控制它。他们说，嗯，美国人本该阻止它的。美国国务卿当时在睡觉。美国国务卿本该把这一切都处理好的。但有时这根本不是大国的问题。这不在他们的能力范围之内。你知道的，格雷已经尽其所能了。嗯，我也认为，因为他能接触到所有的电报和文件，而且他是内阁中比任何人都更专注于此的人，他在想，我们不可能为这事去打仗。我们的利益与此
not directly tied to it. It just seems unbelievable. But the truth of the fact that they're kind of trapped in this system is dawning on him faster than it is on his other colleagues. Oh, definitely. I think definitely by this point, the 28th, 29th, I think definitely by this point at the back of his mind, I think there's a cold feeling that you get when you know there's no escaping the disaster, but you just don't want to admit it to everybody else. But actually, as I've said, I don't think London is the great cockpit of this story. I mean, we're telling it from a British perspective because
not directly tied to it. It just seems unbelievable. But the truth of the fact that they're kind of trapped in this system is dawning on him faster than it is on his other colleagues. Oh, definitely. I think definitely by this point, the 28th, 29th, I think definitely by this point at the back of his mind, I think there's a cold feeling that you get when you know there's no escaping the disaster, but you just don't want to admit it to everybody else. But actually, as I've said, I don't think London is the great cockpit of this story. I mean, we're telling it from a British perspective because|||没有直接挂钩。这看起来简直难以置信。但他们被困在这个系统中的事实，比他的其他同僚更快地在他心中显现出来。哦，肯定的。我认为绝对是在这个时候，28日、29日，我认为绝对在这个时候，在他的脑海深处，有一种冰冷的感觉——当你明知无法逃避这场灾难，却又不想向其他人承认时，就会产生的那种感觉。但实际上，正如我所说，我不认为伦敦是这个故事的主要争夺中心。我的意思是，我们是从英国的视角来讲述这个故事的，因为
we're British, but also because Britain is at this point the world's greatest power. So it makes a huge difference whether Britain's in the war or not. But the people who are driving it are Vienna, Belgrade, Berlin and St. Petersburg. Yeah. But also we're looking at Britain because Britain hasn't yet made up its mind, whereas all the other participants have. Or have they? Because that morning, our old friend the Kaiser wakes up in Potsdam. And of course, he still thinks there's not going to be a war, hopes there's not going to be a war. And he is delighted to wake to a telegram. See, this is the reason we began with Corfu, with that letter.
we're British, but also because Britain is at this point the world's greatest power. So it makes a huge difference whether Britain's in the war or not. But the people who are driving it are Vienna, Belgrade, Berlin and St. Petersburg. Yeah. But also we're looking at Britain because Britain hasn't yet made up its mind, whereas all the other participants have. Or have they? Because that morning, our old friend the Kaiser wakes up in Potsdam. And of course, he still thinks there's not going to be a war, hopes there's not going to be a war. And he is delighted to wake to a telegram. See, this is the reason we began with Corfu, with that letter.|||我们是英国人，也因为英国在此时是世界上最强大的力量。所以英国是否参战有着巨大的影响。但真正推动这一切的是维也纳、贝尔格莱德、柏林和圣彼得堡。是的。但我们也在审视英国，因为英国尚未下定决心，而所有其他参与者都已经下定决心了。真的是这样吗？因为就在那天早晨，我们的老朋友德皇在波茨坦醒来。当然，他仍然认为不会爆发战争，希望不会爆发战争。他高兴地醒来，看到了一封电报。看，这就是我们从科孚岛、从那封信开始讲起的原因。
He wakes to one of these messages from Nicky, his cousin, the Tsar. And the Tsar says, you know, this is a very serious moment. I need your help. None of us want a war. I beg you in the name of our old friendship to do what you can to stop your allies from going too far. By which he means Austria-Hungary. Now, this telegram was Nicholas's own personal idea. Nicholas is in some ways a very irritating man.
He wakes to one of these messages from Nicky, his cousin, the Tsar. And the Tsar says, you know, this is a very serious moment. I need your help. None of us want a war. I beg you in the name of our old friendship to do what you can to stop your allies from going too far. By which he means Austria-Hungary. Now, this telegram was Nicholas's own personal idea. Nicholas is in some ways a very irritating man.|||他醒来时看到了来自他的表弟、沙皇尼基（Nicky）的这样一条信息。沙皇说：“你知道，这是一个非常严重的时刻。我需要你的帮助。我们谁都不想要战争。我以我们昔日的友谊之名恳求你，尽你所能阻止你的盟友们走得太远。”他指的就是奥匈帝国。现在，这封电报是尼古拉个人的主意。尼古拉在某些方面是一个非常惹人厌烦的人。
He's very autocratic. He's very stubborn. He's too reactionary, all of that stuff. But he hates the thought of war. He abhors it. And he is desperate to stop it. And he's surrounded by ministers who are egging him on to sign mobilization orders. And he says, I want to send my cousin a telegram that will sort this out.
He's very autocratic. He's very stubborn. He's too reactionary, all of that stuff. But he hates the thought of war. He abhors it. And he is desperate to stop it. And he's surrounded by ministers who are egging him on to sign mobilization orders. And he says, I want to send my cousin a telegram that will sort this out.|||他非常独裁。他非常顽固。他太反动了，诸如此类。但他讨厌战争的想法。他对战争深恶痛绝。他迫切想要阻止战争。他身边围绕着大臣们，他们怂恿他签署动员令。而他说：“我想给我的表弟发一封电报，这能把事情解决。”
Now, as it happens, it overlaps with one that Willi has sent him. And Willi has sent him a telegram that says, I'm trying to restrain the Austrians, which I have to say he sort of is, but the other people in Berlin are not. And he says, come on, Nicky, you and I hate terrorists and regicides. These people should get their deserved punishment, Wilhelm says in this telegram. I understand how difficult it is for you and your government to face the drift of your public opinion, but please help me to resolve this. So they've both got these telegrams. And then Vili writes another one.
Now, as it happens, it overlaps with one that Willi has sent him. And Willi has sent him a telegram that says, I'm trying to restrain the Austrians, which I have to say he sort of is, but the other people in Berlin are not. And he says, come on, Nicky, you and I hate terrorists and regicides. These people should get their deserved punishment, Wilhelm says in this telegram. I understand how difficult it is for you and your government to face the drift of your public opinion, but please help me to resolve this. So they've both got these telegrams. And then Vili writes another one.|||现在，碰巧的是，这与威利（Willi）发给他的电报重合了。威利发给他一封电报说：“我正在试图克制奥地利人”——我必须说他确实在某种程度上这么做了，但柏林的其他其他人并没有。他说：“拜托，尼基，你我都讨厌恐怖分子和弑君者。这些人应该受到他们应得的惩罚，”威利在这封电报中说道。“我理解你和你的政府面对公众舆论走向时的困难，但请帮我解决这个问题。”所以他们俩都收到了这些电报。然后威利又写了另一封。
And he says, listen, I think the Austrians are behaving in self-defense. I promise you they won't seize any Serbian territory. They won't annex it after the war is over. Please don't mobilize your armies because I'm hoping to mediate between you and the Austrians. And that would make it impossible for me to do so. So Wilhelm sends this. Now, Nicholas, he's not the sharpest tool in the cutlery drawer, the Tsar.
And he says, listen, I think the Austrians are behaving in self-defense. I promise you they won't seize any Serbian territory. They won't annex it after the war is over. Please don't mobilize your armies because I'm hoping to mediate between you and the Austrians. And that would make it impossible for you to do so. So Wilhelm sends this. Now, Nicholas, he's not the sharpest tool in the cutlery drawer, the Tsar.|||他说：“听着，我认为奥地利人的行为是在进行自卫。我向你保证，他们不会夺取任何塞尔维亚领土。战争结束后他们也不会吞并它。请不要动员你们的军队，因为我希望在你和奥地利人之间进行调解。而这样做会让我无法进行调解。”于是威利把这个发了出去。现在，尼古拉，这位沙皇可真不是餐具抽屉里最锋利的工具。
He gets this telegram that evening. And he he says, oh my God, this is brilliant. Cousin Vili has come through after all. And he rings, you know how much he hates using the phone. He rings the foreign minister and he says, great news. The Kaiser hates the thought of war. So do I. I've actually been thinking and I have changed my mind. I don't like the thought of going to war at all.
He gets this telegram that evening. And he he says, oh my God, this is brilliant. Cousin Vili has come through after all. And he rings, you know how much he hates using the phone. He rings the foreign minister and he says, great news. The Kaiser hates the thought of war. So do I. I've actually been thinking and I have changed my mind. I don't like the thought of going to war at all.|||他那天晚上收到了这封电报。他说道：“哦天哪，这太棒了。表弟威利关键时刻还是靠得住的。”他打电话——你知道他有多讨厌使用电话。他打电话给外交大臣说：“好消息。德皇讨厌战争的想法。我也一样。我其实一直在思考，而且我已经改变主意了。我一点也不喜欢打仗的想法。”
When Sassanoff, the foreign minister, hears this, he is gutted. Because actually all day, he and the other ministers have been deciding what to do, and they have decided they will go for a general mobilisation. Now, I think this is sometimes underrated, especially in popular histories that take a very kind of anti-German line because this is a massive step in the escalation of the crisis because nobody yet has had a general mobilization not even the Austrians no definitely not the Germans no the Germans are nowhere near it so for the Russians to have done this now look I understand why they did it they think they've got to steal a march on everybody else because they happen to be so big and lumbering and slow. But for them to do this, as Thomas Otte says in his book, July Crisis, which is actually
When Sassanoff, the foreign minister, hears this, he is gutted. Because actually all day, he and the other ministers have been deciding what to do, and they have decided they will go for a general mobilisation. Now, I think this is sometimes underrated, especially in popular histories that take a very kind of anti-German line because this is a massive step in the escalation of the crisis because nobody yet has had a general mobilization not even the Austrians no definitely not the Germans no the Germans are nowhere near it so for the Russians to have done this now look I understand why they did it they think they've got to steal a march on everybody else because they happen to be so big and lumbering and slow. But for them to do this, as Thomas Otte says in his book, July Crisis, which is actually|||当外交大臣萨萨诺夫（Sassanoff）听到这个消息时，他心碎欲绝。因为实际上整整一天，他和另外几位大臣一直在决定该怎么做，并且他们已经决定要进行总动员。现在，我认为这有时被低估了，特别是在那些采取非常反德路线的通俗历史中，因为这是危机升级过程中的巨大一步，因为当时还没有人进行总动员——甚至连奥地利人都没有，不，绝对没有，德国人也没有，不，德国人离那还远得很。所以对于俄国人来说，现在竟然这样做了——看，我理解他们为什么这么做，他们认为他们必须抢在所有人前面占得先机，因为他们恰好又大又笨重又迟缓。但正如托马斯·奥特（Thomas Otte）在他的书《七月危机》（July Crisis）中所说的那样，他们竟然这样做了——这本书实际上
very critical of Germany and Austria, but he says of Russia at this point, they rushed into this decision. The Austrians were still maybe 10 days off from a full attack on Serbia, so there was still time. They didn't need to force the pace of events in this way. And that once the Russians had gone down that road, it's really hard to see how you get out of this without a war. Because that's terrifying for the Germans. Absolutely. To have this massive great leviathan on your doorstep mobilizing. Of course. Imagine a similar situation now. Imagine if suddenly you heard that Russian
very critical of Germany and Austria, but he says of Russia at this point, they rushed into this decision. The Austrians were still maybe 10 days off from a full attack on Serbia, so there was still time. They didn't need to force the pace of events in this way. And that once the Russians had gone down that road, it's really hard to see how you get out of this without a war. Because that's terrifying for the Germans. Absolutely. To have this massive great leviathan on your doorstep mobilizing. Of course. Imagine a similar situation now. Imagine if suddenly you heard that Russian|||对德国和奥地利持强烈批评态度，但他在谈到此时的俄国时说，他们仓促作出了这个决定。奥地利人距离对塞尔维亚发动全面进攻可能还有10天左右的时间，所以时间还来得及。他们没必要以这种方式强行加快事件的步伐。而且一旦俄国人走上了这条路，真的很难看出怎么才能在不爆发战争的情况下摆脱困境。因为这对于德国人来说太可怕了。绝对是的。家门口有这样一个庞大的利维坦（巨兽）在进行动员。当然。想象一下现在类似的情况。想象一下，如果你突然听说俄国
troops are massing on the borders of Poland or something. I mean, you don't think, oh, they'll probably just all go home afterwards. You think, oh my God, this is war. We have to immediately act. Otherwise they'll just walk straight in. That's what the Germans think. Now, the thing is, the Tsar knows this, Nicholas. And when he hears this, he says, no, these are his words, I will not be responsible for a monstrous slaughter and quite rightly he says to his ministers war would be disastrous for the world once it had broken out it would be difficult to stop the german emperor had frequently assured him of his sincere desire to safeguard the peace of europe and it had always been possible to come to an agreement with the kaiser even in serious cases and And you know what? If those
troops are massing on the borders of Poland or something. I mean, you don't think, oh, they'll probably just all go home afterwards. You think, oh my God, this is war. We have to immediately act. Otherwise they'll just walk straight in. That's what the Germans think. Now, the thing is, the Tsar knows this, Nicholas. And when he hears this, he says, no, these are his words, I will not be responsible for a monstrous slaughter and quite rightly he says to his ministers war would be disastrous for the world once it had broken out it would be difficult to stop the german emperor had frequently assured him of his sincere desire to safeguard the peace of europe and it had always been possible to come to an agreement with the kaiser even in serious cases and And you know what? If those|||军队正在波兰边境或其他地方集结。我的意思是，你不会认为，哦，他们事后大概都会回家的。你会想，哦天哪，这是战争。我们必须立即采取行动。否则他们就会长驱直入。德国人就是这么想的。现在，问题是，沙皇尼古拉知道这一点。当他听到这个消息时，他说——不，这是他的原话——“我不会为一场骇人听闻的大屠杀负责”，并且他非常正确地对大臣们说，战争对世界来说将是灾难性的，一旦爆发就很难停止，德国皇帝曾多次向他保证其真诚维护欧洲和平的愿望，并且即使在严重的情况下，也总是能够与德皇达成协议。你知道吗？如果那些
monarchs had had as much power as people often think they did, then there would have been no world war. There's no doubt in my mind about that. So basically, if the Russians hadn't made the Tsar more of a constitutional monarch, if he'd really had remained as autocratic as he'd been before the defeat at the hands of the Japanese, then maybe there wouldn't have been a world war. There's an engaging irony. Well, maybe. I mean, I think the trouble is, of course, that there are very few genuinely autocratic monarchs.
monarchs had had as much power as people often think they did, then there would have been no world war. There's no doubt in my mind about that. So basically, if the Russians hadn't made the Tsar more of a constitutional monarch, if he'd really had remained as autocratic as he'd been before the defeat at the hands of the Japanese, then maybe there wouldn't have been a world war. There's an engaging irony. Well, maybe. I mean, I think the trouble is, of course, that there are very few genuinely autocratic monarchsthat|||君主拥有人们通常认为的那样大的权力，那么就不会有世界大战了。对此我深信不疑。所以基本上，如果俄国人没有让沙皇变成一个更多意义上的君主立宪制君主，如果他真的保持着在被日本人击败之前那种专制独裁，那么也许就不会有世界大战了。这是一个引人入胜的讽刺。嗯，也许吧。我的意思是，我认为麻烦当然在于，真正专制独裁的君主少之又少，
You know, when you're surrounded by an elite who all think one thing and are telling you, you must do this, Your Majesty, you must do this, it's very hard to say no. And actually what happens is, they have the order ready to go to the telegraph office. He put his foot down and said, no, Nicholas. They didn't send the order to the telegraph office, but in secret, his general staff carried on making preparations all that night. And they just think
You know, when you're surrounded by an elite who all think one thing and are telling you, you must do this, Your Majesty, you must do this, it's very hard to say no. And actually what happens is, they have the order ready to go to the telegraph office. He put his foot down and said, no, Nicholas. They didn't send the order to the telegraph office, but in secret, his general staff carried on making preparations all that night. And they just think|||你知道的，当你被一群想法完全一致、并且对你说“陛下，您必须这么做，您必须这么做”的精英环绕时，拒绝是非常困难的。实际上发生的事情是，他们已经准备好了发往电报局的命令。他态度坚决地说：“不，尼古拉。”他们没有把命令发到电报局，但在暗地里，他的总参谋部整晚都在继续做着准备工作。他们只是认为
we'll twist his arm later on and persuade him. So that's what's been happening in St. Petersburg. Now, meanwhile, in Berlin, again, some of the Kaiser's ministers, like Erich von Falkenhayn, are saying, we must move now to a thing called a state of imminent war. They proclaim that war is very likely and we have to take measures. And the Chancellor, Bethlehem Holweg, no, it's much too much of an escalation. We need to gain time for further talks. And of course, the Kaiser is still going on about his schemes. So he still says, you know, I don't know why you rejected my plan for a podcast on Chatham High Street.
we'll twist his arm later on and persuade him. So that's what's been happening in St. Petersburg. Now, meanwhile, in Berlin, again, some of the Kaiser's ministers, like Erich von Falkenhayn, are saying, we must move now to a thing called a state of imminent war. They proclaim that war is very likely and we have to take measures. And the Chancellor, Bethlehem Holweg, no, it's much too much of an escalation. We need to gain time for further talks. And of course, the Kaiser is still going on about his schemes. So he still says, you know, I don't know why you rejected my plan for a podcast on Chatham High Street.|||我们过一会儿再软磨硬泡说服他。这就是圣彼得堡发生的事情。与此同时，在柏林，德皇的一些大臣，比如埃里希·冯·法金汉（Erich von Falkenhayn），再次表示：“我们现在必须进入一个被称为‘濒临战争状态’的事情。”他们宣称战争极有可能爆发，我们必须采取措施。而首相贝特曼·霍尔维格（Bethmann-Hollweg）则认为，不，这升级得太厉害了。我们需要为进一步的会谈争取时间。当然，德皇还在喋喋不休地谈论他的计划。所以他依然说：“你知道的，我不知道你们为什么拒绝我在查塔姆商业街（Chatham High Street）做播客的计划。”
He's not wrong. Stop in Belgrade. You know, it's a great idea. I've had a lot of grief from people who frankly don't know what they're talking about. And actually, I've got very good news. Because at this point, the Kaiser has been visited by his younger brother, Prince Heinrich of Russia.
He's not wrong. Stop in Belgrade. You know, it's a great idea. I've had a lot of grief from people who frankly don't know what they're talking about. And actually, I've got very good news. Because at this point, the Kaiser has been visited by his younger brother, Prince Heinrich of Russia.|||他没有错。在贝尔格莱德停下。你知道，这是一个好主意。我从那些坦率地说根本不知道自己在说什么的人那里受到了很多委屈。事实上，我有个好消息。因为就在这个时候，德皇接待了他的弟弟、俄罗斯的亨利亲王（Prince Heinrich of Russia）。
Oh, who's been yachting at cows. Who's been yachting at cows. We do love a member of the German royal family going on a yacht trip to cows, don't we? Well, Prince Heinrich has been yachting at cows. He's just got back to Germany and he says, amazing news, brilliant news. I can't wait to tell you. I saw Cousin George, this is George V at Buckingham Palace. And Cousin George said to me, I don't know what we shall do. We have't wait to tell you. I saw Cousin George. This is George V at Buckingham Palace.
Oh, who's been yachting at cows. Who's been yachting at cows. We do love a member of the German royal family going on a yacht trip to cows, don't we? Well, Prince Heinrich has been yachting at cows. He's just got back to Germany and he says, amazing news, brilliant news. I can't wait to tell you. I saw Cousin George, this is George V at Buckingham Palace. And Cousin George said to me, I don't know what we shall do. We have't wait to tell you. I saw Cousin George. This is George V at Buckingham Palace.|||哦，他一直在考斯（Cowes）玩游艇。他一直在考斯玩游艇。我们真的很喜欢看到德国王室成员去考斯进行游艇旅行，不是吗？好吧，亨利亲王一直在考斯玩游艇。他刚回到德国，并说道：“惊人的消息，太棒的消息。我迫不及待地想告诉你。我见到了乔治表弟，这是白金汉宫的乔治五世。乔治表弟对我说，我不知道我们该怎么办。我们——等等，我迫不及待要告诉你。我见到了乔治表弟。这是白金汉宫的乔治五世。
And Cousin George said to me, I don't know what we shall do. We have no quarrel with anyone. I hope we shall remain neutral. I and my government will do all that we can to stop this war. Is that what he sounded like? He sort of turned into the Queen Mother there. That was just a poor choice of voice from me. Yeah, all right.
And Cousin George said to me, I don't know what we shall do. We have no quarrel with anyone. I hope we shall remain neutral. I and my government will do all that we can to stop this war. Is that what he sounded like? He sort of turned into the Queen Mother there. That was just a poor choice of voice from me. Yeah, all right.|||乔治表弟对我说：‘我不知道我们该怎么办。我们与任何人都没有争执。我希望我们能保持中立。我和我的政府将尽我们所能阻止这场战争。’”他听起来是那样吗？他在那儿简直有点变成王太后了。那只是我模仿声音时选得不太好。好吧，没关系。
But I think we should leave it in, Tom, because I want people to see we don't always hit the bullseye every time. But maybe he did sound like that. Maybe he did. Yeah. Let's say that he did though he was a bluff naval type wasn't he yes i don't know what we should do we've had churchill already we don't want too much crossover that's true anyway the kaiser hears this and the kaiser he's very impulsive and he says oh absolutely brilliant the british definitely won't enter the war then if cousin george doesn't like the thought of it. And actually, he meets his admirals that evening and they're talking about, you know, what we do about Britain, blah, blah, blah. He says, what, Britain?
But I think we should leave it in, Tom, because I want people to see we don't always hit the bullseye every time. But maybe he did sound like that. Maybe he did. Yeah. Let's say that he did though he was a bluff naval type wasn't he yes i don't know what we should do we've had churchill already we don't want too much crossover that's true anyway the kaiser hears this and the kaiser he's very impulsive and he says oh absolutely brilliant the british definitely won't enter the war then if cousin george doesn't like the thought of it. And actually, he meets his admirals that evening and they're talking about, you know, what we do about Britain, blah, blah, blah. He says, what, Britain?|||但我认为我们应该把它保留下来，汤姆，因为我想让人们看到我们并非每次都能正中靶心。但也许他听起来确实那样。也许是的。好吧。我们就当他是那样吧——尽管他是一个直率的海军军人，不是吗？是的，“我不知道我们该怎么办”——我们已经有丘吉尔了，我们不想有太多重叠。这倒也是。无论如何，德皇听到这个消息后，德皇他非常冲动，他说：“哦，太棒了，如果乔治表弟不喜欢这个想法，那么英国人绝对不会参战了。”事实上，他在那天晚上会见了海军将领们，他们谈论着，你知道的，我们该如何对付英国等等之类的话题。他说：“什么，英国？
Britain's not going to be part of the war. They will stay out. And then he says, I mean, it's almost touching. He says, I have the word of a king. That's good enough for me. Do you know, he's really going up in my estimation. And they're kind of, you can imagine them all sort of slightly frowning and shuffling
Britain's not going to be part of the war. They will stay out. And then he says, I mean, it's almost touching. He says, I have the word of a king. That's good enough for me. Do you know, he's really going up in my estimation. And they're kind of, you can imagine them all sort of slightly frowning and shuffling|||英国不会卷入这场战争。他们会置身事外。”然后他说——我的意思是，这几乎令人感动。他说：“我有一个国王的承诺。这对我就足够了。你知道吗，他在我心目中的分量真的上升了。”他们有点——你可以想象他们所有人都有点微微皱眉，拖着步子，
and looking at the floor in embarrassment but actually at that very meeting they get shocking news from russia that the russian partial mobilization the mobilization of the four western districts has begun that the russian troops are now beginning to get onto the trains move to the railway stations move towards the frontier i just to be clear, this means the storm clouds of war are really getting dark, doesn't it? They're incredibly dark, Tom. The tinderbox has been lit, I think it's fair to say, if you light a tinderbox or strike a tinderbox, whatever.
and looking at the floor in embarrassment but actually at that very meeting they get shocking news from russia that the russian partial mobilization the mobilization of the four western districts has begun that the russian troops are now beginning to get onto the trains move to the railway stations move towards the frontier i just to be clear, this means the storm clouds of war are really getting dark, doesn't it? They're incredibly dark, Tom. The tinderbox has been lit, I think it's fair to say, if you light a tinderbox or strike a tinderbox, whatever.|||尴尬地看着地板，但实际上就在那次会议上，他们收到了来自俄国的令人震惊的消息：俄国的局部动员——四个西部军区的动员已经开始，俄国军队现在开始登上火车，前往火车站，向边境移动——为了把话说清楚，这意味着战争的乌云真的变得越来越阴暗了，不是吗？它们黑得难以想象，汤姆。可以说火药桶已经被点燃了，如果你点燃了火药桶或者划燃了火药桶，随便怎么说吧。
Well, the rain from the storm clouds of war might put the tinderbox out, but it mustn't mix our metaphors. It might. But for all of these politicians, these Germans, so for Bethmann-Holweg, for the foreign minister, Yagov, for all of these politicians, these Germans, so for Bethlehem and Holweg, for the foreign minister, Yagov, for all these people, this is a genuinely traumatic moment. For weeks, they have been saying our deterrents will do the trick, the Russians, they'll be cross, but they won't follow through.
Well, the rain from the storm clouds of war might put the tinderbox out, but it mustn't mix our metaphors. It might. But for all of these politicians, these Germans, so for Bethmann-Holweg, for the foreign minister, Yagov, for all of these politicians, these Germans, so for Bethlehem and Holweg, for the foreign minister, Yagov, for all these people, this is a genuinely traumatic moment. For weeks, they have been saying our deterrents will do the trick, the Russians, they'll be cross, but they won't follow through.|||好吧，战争乌云带来的雨水可能会把火药桶浇灭，但我们不能把隐喻搞混了。也许会吧。但对所有这些政治家、这些德国人来说——所以对贝特曼·霍尔维格（Bethmann-Hollweg）、对外长雅戈夫（Jagow）而言，对所有这些政治家、这些德国人来说——所以对贝特曼和霍尔维格、外长雅戈夫、所有这些人来说，这是一个真正的创伤性时刻。几个星期以来，他们一直说我们的威慑会起作用，俄国人虽然会生气，但他们不会付诸行动。
And suddenly they think, oh God, everything we've said was rubbish. So a bit like if Putin suddenly was to use a battlefield nuclear weapon. Yeah. The assumption that this is a step that the Russians won't take. Yeah. And then they do. And then they do. And I think there's no doubt it is a genuine shock.
And suddenly they think, oh God, everything we've said was rubbish. So a bit like if Putin suddenly was to use a battlefield nuclear weapon. Yeah. The assumption that this is a step that the Russians won't take. Yeah. And then they do. And then they do. And I think there's no doubt it is a genuine shock.|||突然之间他们想，哦天哪，我们说过的一切都是废话。所以这有点像普京突然使用战术核武器一样。是的。假设这是俄国人不会采取的一步。是的。然后他们真的用了。然后他们真的用了。而且我认为毫无疑问，这是一个真正的震撼。
Falkenhayn, the war minister, says, right, OK, this is it now. We have to mobilize. And actually still, the chancellor, Bethlehem Holweg, says, no, we must wait to the last possible minute. If there is going to be war, it's actually much better for the Russians to start it. That will show the world that we are the injured party. And Falkenhayn gives in. He says, well, I don't want to, but it's not my job to tell you, the politicians, what to do. We think of the German system as so militaristic, But still, the civilians are in control, which is not what all historians, I think, say. But I think it is the case. So overnight, actually, so we're now
Falkenhayn, the war minister, says, right, OK, this is it now. We have to mobilize. And actually still, the chancellor, Bethlehem Holweg, says, no, must wait to the last possible minute. If there is going to be war, it's actually much better for the Russians to start it. That will show the world that we are the injured party. And Falkenhayn gives in. He says, well, I don't want to, but it's not my job to tell you, the politicians, what to do. We think of the German system as so militaristic, But still, the civilians are in control, which is not what all historians, I think, say. But I think it is the case. So overnight, actually, so we're now|||战争大臣法金汉说：“好，好吧，就是现在了。我们必须进行动员。”但实际上，首相贝特曼·霍尔维格仍然说：“不，我们必须等到最后一分钟。如果非要爆发战争，由俄国人来挑起实际上要好得多。那将向世界展示我们是受害者。”法金汉让步了。他说：“好吧，我不想这样，但告诉你们这些政治家该怎么做不是我的工作。”我们认为德国体制非常军国主义，但文官仍然在掌控局面，我认为并非所有历史学家都这么说。但我认为事实确实如此。所以实际上就在一夜之间，所以我们现在
moving towards Thursday, the 30th of July. Overnight, the Germans slightly are changing their tune. And they're actually sending a lot of very panicked telegrams to the Austrians, saying, actually, that idea of the Kaiser's about stopping in Belgrade. Yeah, it's quite a good one. So it's like, you, actually, let's of the Kaiser's about stopping in Belgrade. Yeah, it's quite a good one. So it's like you. Actually, let's go to Chatham. Yeah, exactly it is, Tom. No doubt that will happen.
moving towards Thursday, the 30th of July. Overnight, the Germans slightly are changing their tune. And they're actually sending a lot of very panicked telegrams to the Austrians, saying, actually, that idea of the Kaiser's about stopping in Belgrade. Yeah, it's quite a good one. So it's like, you, actually, let's of the Kaiser's about stopping in Belgrade. Yeah, it's quite a good one. So it's like you. Actually, let's go to Chatham. Yeah, exactly it is, Tom. No doubt that will happen.|||正走向7月30日星期四。一夜之间，德国人的基调微微发生了一些变化。他们实际上向奥地利人发送了大量非常惊慌失措的电报，说道：“其实，德皇关于在贝尔格莱德停下的那个主意。是的，挺不错的。”所以就像是，你，实际上，让我们——德皇关于在贝尔格莱德停下的主意。是的，挺不错的。所以就像你一样。实际上，让我们去查塔姆吧。是的，确实如此，汤姆。毫无疑问那会发生的。
I'm sure it will. Well, I promised you that it will happen. And it will happen. So they say to the Austrians, look, would you not consider it? And the Austrians, of course, say, whoa, you can't do this to us now. For more than a month, you've told us, do what you like, we'll stand by you. We've made all our plans. We've gone public. We've got our army vaguely ready. I mean, it's the Austrian army, so they're not quite ready. They say, why should we back down
I'm sure it will. Well, I promised you that it will happen. And it will happen. So they say to the Austrians, look, would you not consider it? And the Austrians, of course, say, whoa, you can't do this to us now. For more than a month, you've told us, do what you like, we'll stand by you. We've made all our plans. We've gone public. We've got our army vaguely ready. I mean, it's the Austrian army, so they're not quite ready. They say, why should we back down|||我确信会的。好吧，我向你保证这会发生的。而且它一定会发生。所以他们对奥地利人说：“听着，你们不考虑一下吗？”而奥地利人当然会说：“哇，你们现在不能这样对我们。一个多月来，你们告诉我们，‘随便你们怎么做，我们会支持你们的’。我们已经做好了所有的计划。我们已经公开表态了。我们的军队也差不多准备好了。”——我的意思是，这是奥地利军队，所以他们并没有完全准备好。他们说：“我们为什么要退缩
now? Franz Josef says, what? Because the Russians are bullying you, we should give in. He says, if I stop now and agree to mediation, it will mean another rescue of Serbia by Russian intervention. And basically, the Austrians make a fair point. This would send a signal that we can never act again. If we stop now, having sent our ultimatum, having prepared all the ground, all this, this will basically say to our neighbours, the world will never let us react, never let us defend ourselves, never let us respond. Absolutely not are we going to stop in Belgrade or abandon our military action. We've committed to this. We're going on with it. Now, that said, the Austrians know at this point they're facing a terrible mess because they're actually behind the scenes in a massive panic about Russian
now? Franz Josef says, what? Because the Russians are bullying you, we should give in. He says, if I stop now and agree to mediation, it will mean another rescue of Serbia by Russian intervention. And basically, the Austrians make a fair point. This would send a signal that we can never act again. If we stop now, having sent our ultimatum, having prepared all the ground, all this, this will basically say to our neighbours, the world will never let us react, never let us defend ourselves, never let us respond. Absolutely not are we going to stop in Belgrade or abandon our military action. We've committed to this. We're going on with it. Now, that said, the Austrians know at this point they're facing a terrible mess because they're actually behind the scenes in a massive panic about Russian|||现在？弗朗茨·约瑟夫说：‘什么？因为俄国人欺负你们，我们就该屈服吗？’”他说：“如果我现在停下来并同意调解，那就意味着俄国人的干预又一次拯救了塞尔维亚。”基本上，奥地利人提出了一个合理的观点。这会发出一个信号，即我们再也不能采取行动了。如果我们现在停下来，在发出了最后通牒、铺平了所有道路、做了这一切之后，这基本上是在告诉我们的邻居，世界永远不会让我们反应，永远不会让我们保护自己，永远不会让我们做出回应。我们绝对不会在贝尔格莱德停下来，也不会放弃我们的军事行动。我们已经致力于此了。我们将继续进行下去。话虽如此，奥地利人此时知道他们面临着一个可怕的烂摊子，因为他们在幕后实际上对俄国人的
intervention. The politicians have said to Conrad, actually, should we maybe turn the troops around and send them east to the frontier with Russia? And that means getting them on trains and things. Yeah. And he says, that's mad. You can't have half the trains going west, the others going east. They'll kind of cancel each other out. They'll meet in the middle. And there'll be gridlock on the railways. Unbelievably, he says, what we'll do is we'll send the entire army south. They'll get off the trains. Then we'll physically turn the trains around. And they'll get back on the train and go all the way back the other way. So that gives you a sense of the seriousness, Tom, and the efficiency of the Austrian war efforts. So that's what's going on in Austria. In Berlin, a terrible thing has happened. Very sad given the reading that we
intervention. The politicians have said to Conrad, actually, should we maybe turn the troops around and send them east to the frontier with Russia? And that means getting them on trains and things. Yeah. And he says, that's mad. You can't have half the trains going west, the others going east. They'll kind of cancel each other out. They'll meet in the middle. And there'll be gridlock on the railways. Unbelievably, he says, what we'll do is we'll send the entire army south. They'll get off the trains. Then we'll physically turn the trains around. And they'll get back on the train and go all the way back the other way. So that gives you a sense of the seriousness, Tom, and the efficiency of the Austrian war efforts. So that's what's going on in Austria. In Berlin, a terrible thing has happened. Very sad given the reading that we|||干预感到极度恐慌。政治家们对康拉德（Conrad）说：“实际上，我们是不是应该把军队掉头，把他们派往东部与俄国接壤的边境？”这意味着让他们上火车之类的。是的。而他说：“这太疯狂了。你不能让一半的火车向西开，另一半向东开。它们会在某种程度上互相抵消。它们会在中间相遇。铁路会陷入瘫痪。”难以置信的是，他说：“我们要做的就是把整支军队派往南方。他们下车。然后我们把火车物理掉头。他们再上火车，一路往回开。”所以这让你对奥地利战争努力的严肃性和效率有了切身的体会，汤姆。这就是奥地利正在发生的事情。在柏林，发生了一件可怕的事情。鉴于我们一开始的朗读，这真是令人难过，
began with. The Kaiser has got another telegram from the Tsar and he's not pleased by what he reads. So the invitation to the Acheleion is cancelled. Yeah. Do you know what? I don't want a massive spoiler. That Corfu holiday is never going to happen. It's never going to happen. Because Nicholas II says, yes, it's true.
began with. The Kaiser has got another telegram from the Tsar and he's not pleased by what he reads. So the invitation to the Acheleion is cancelled. Yeah. Do you know what? I don't want a massive spoiler. That Corfu holiday is never going to happen. It's never going to happen. Because Nicholas II says, yes, it's true.|||德皇收到了沙皇发来的另一封电报，他对读到的内容很不高兴。所以去阿基琉宫（Acheleion）的邀请被取消了。是的。你知道吗？我不想剧透太多。那个科孚岛假期永远不会发生了。它永远不会发生了。因为尼古拉二世说：“是的，这是真的。
We are doing a bit of a partial mobilization. But I promise you it has nothing to do with the telegrams because actually we've been planning it for days. And of course, when the Kaiser hears that we've been planning it for days he says what they've been planning behind my back all this time and who does he blame for this well who do you think he blames a country of mean shopkeepers who sneer at him for his choice of footwear at yachting regattas yeah so that afternoon that Thursday, the 30th of July, is just going around ranting.
We are doing a bit of a partial mobilization. But I promise you it has nothing to do with the telegrams because actually we've been planning it for days. And. Of course, when the Kaiser hears that we've been planning it for days he says what they've been planning behind my back all this time and who does he blame for this well who do you think he blames a country of mean shopkeepers who sneer at him for his choice of footwear at yachting regattas yeah so that afternoon that Thursday, the 30th of July, is just going around ranting.|||我们正在进行一点局部的总动员。但我向你保证，这与那些电报毫无关系，因为实际上我们已经策划好几天了。”当然，当德皇听到我们已经策划了好几天时，他说：“什么？他们这段时间一直在我的背后策划这个？”他把这怪罪于谁呢？嗯，你觉得他会怪谁？一个吝啬的店主之国，他们在游艇帆船赛上对他的鞋子选择嗤之以鼻。是的，所以在7月30日星期四的那个下午，他到处大发雷霆。
He's very upset. He feels so betrayed. Our enemies have planned a terrible war to destroy Germany. And he says, I'm going to read the whole quote. So the famous encirclement has become an accomplished fact. The net has suddenly been pulled over our head and sneeringly England reaps the most brilliant success of our stubbornly pursued,
He's very upset. He feels so betrayed. Our enemies have planned a terrible war to destroy Germany. And he says, I'm going to read the whole quote. So the famous encirclement has become an accomplished fact. The net has suddenly been pulled over our head and sneeringly England reaps the most brilliant success of our stubbornly pursued,|||他非常沮丧。他觉得自己受到了极大的背叛。我们的敌人策划了一场可怕的战争来毁灭德国。他说：“我要读出完整的引文。”因此，著名的包围圈已经成为既成事实。网突然被拉到了我们的头上，而英国带着嘲讽收获了我们顽固追求的
purely anti-German world policy against which we are powerless while she twists the noose of our political and economic destruction as we squirm isolated in the net. And then he just has this mad kind of shriek of rage. He says, Edward VII is stronger after death than i am who was still
purely anti-German world policy against which we are powerless while she twists the noose of our political and economic destruction as we squirm isolated in the net. And then he just has this mad kind of shriek of rage. He says, Edward VII is stronger after death than i am who was still|||纯粹反德的世界政策的最辉煌的成功，对此我们无能为力，而她则拧紧了我们政治和经济毁灭的绞索，我们在网中孤立地扭动着。然后他发出了一种疯狂的愤怒尖叫。他说：“爱德华七世死后比我这个还活着的人更强大。”
alive so actually uncle eddie who he's always hated because uncle edward despised philhelm and treated him like an absolute buffoon aberration and sneered at him and put him down sent him terrible christmas presents yeah and And he says, I knew it. Fine, he's been dead for however many years, but he plotted this. Uncle Edward, I knew it. And all of this stuff. I mean, it's actually tragic, I think, in some ways, that the Kaiser, who's such a ridiculous and indeed very objectionable man in some ways, but ultimately he's just this little
alive so actually uncle eddie who he's always hated because uncle edward despised philhelm and treated him like an absolute buffoon aberration and sneered at him and put him down sent him terrible christmas presents yeah and And he says, I knew it. Fine, he's been dead for however many years, but he plotted this. Uncle Edward, I knew it. And all of this stuff. I mean, it's actually tragic, I think, in some ways, that the Kaiser, who's such a ridiculous and indeed very objectionable man in some ways, but ultimately he's just this little|||所以实际上，埃迪叔叔——他一直恨他，因为爱德华叔叔鄙视威廉，把他当作一个绝对的小丑怪胎，对他嗤之以鼻，贬低他，送给他糟糕的圣诞礼物，是的，还有——他说：“我知道。好吧，他已经死了不知多少年了，但他策划了这一切。爱德华叔叔，我早就知道了。”以及所有这些东西。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这实际上是个悲剧，我认为，德皇如此荒谬，在某些方面确实是个令人反感的人，但归根结底他只是这个小男孩，
boy, you know, who craved approval and acceptance. It's a bit like Nixon's post-resignation speech where he started crying. This is the Kaiser now. It's like, it's all about him and his family and how he's been betrayed. So now we're at a very serious point. We haven't mentioned the French at all recently because actually the French have been keeping their heads down. Have they still been on their ship? When does their ship get back? They've just got back. And so while they're on their ship, are they getting telegrams?
boy, you know, who craved approval and acceptance. It's a bit like Nixon's post-resignation speech where he started crying. This is the Kaiser now. It's like, it's all about him and his family and how he's been betrayed. So now we're at a very serious point. We haven't mentioned the French at all recently because actually the French have been keeping their heads down. Have they still been on their ship? When does their ship get back? They've just got back. And so while they're on their ship, are they getting telegrams?|||你知道的，他渴望得到认可和接受。这有点像尼克松辞职后的演讲，他在演讲中哭了起来。这就是现在的德皇。这就像是，一切都与他、他的家族以及他如何被背叛有关。所以现在我们到了一个非常严重的关头。我们最近根本没有提到法国人，因为实际上法国人一直夹着尾巴做人。他们还在船上吗？他们的船什么时候回来？他们刚刚回来。所以当他们在船上时，他们能收到电报吗？
Yes, they are in communication. and poor old Rene Viviani, who some people may recall gibbering and sweating. Yeah, I mean, he must be in an absolute blind funk by this point. He is in a funk. He's just sort of, you know, staggering around the deck of the ship, wiping his brow and saying, please, not a war. And Poincaré, who treats him like dirt,
Yes, they are in communication. and poor old Rene Viviani, who some people may recall gibbering and sweating. Yeah, I mean, he must be in an absolute blind funk by this point. He is in a funk. He's just sort of, you know, staggering around the deck of the ship, wiping his brow and saying, please, not a war. And Poincaré, who treats him like dirt,|||是的，他们保持着联系。还有可怜的老勒内·维维亚尼（Rene Viviani），有些人可能还记得他语无伦次、大汗淋漓的样子。是的，我的意思是，到目前为止，他一定处于一种绝对的盲目惊恐状态。他确实很惊恐。他只是——你知道的，在船甲板上蹒跚而行，擦着额头说：“求求你，不要战争。”而蓬加莱（Poincaré）对待他就像对待泥土一样，
treats him like Uncle Edward treats the Kaiser. Or you treat me. No, that's totally... And I come up with brilliant suggestions for podcast episodes. That's totally cruel, Tom. That's not actually the case. Pankow just keeps saying to him, you know nothing of foreign affairs. What do you know about it? We should stand firm, all of this kind of thing.
treats him like Uncle Edward treats the Kaiser. Or you treat me. No, that's totally... And I come up with brilliant suggestions for podcast episodes. That's totally cruel, Tom. That's not actually the case. Pankow just keeps saying to him, you know nothing of foreign affairs. What do you know about it? We should stand firm, all of this kind of thing.|||对待他就像爱德华叔叔对待德皇一样。或者就像你对待我一样。不，这完全……而我提出了绝妙的播客节目建议。这太残酷了，汤姆。事实并非如此。庞加莱只是一直对他说：“你对外交事务一无所知。你懂什么？我们应该立场坚定，”所有这类的话。
So Pankow gets back and he says to everybody, there's going to be no settlement, no deals. We stick by the Russians. Stand up. The Germans clearly want a war. Fine. Let them put themselves in the wrong. We'll start
So Pankow gets back and he says to everybody, there's going to be no settlement, no deals. We stick by the Russians. Stand up. The Germans clearly want a war. Fine. Let them put themselves in the wrong. We'll start|||所以蓬加莱回来了，他对每个人说：“不会有什么妥协，也不会有什么交易。我们支持俄国人。站起来。德国人显然想要战争。很好。让他们把自己置于理亏的境地。我们将开始
to make preparations, but very quietly and subtly, no full mobilization. Keep our troops back from the frontier. They play it very canonally, the French. Crucially, they say the key thing is, and I quote, this is from the Undersecretary for Foreign Affairs, Abel Ferry. He says, we must show to the English public and the English government that France, like Russia, will not be the first to fire. Make the Germans the bad guys, because that will bring in Britain on our side. So that's the atmosphere in France. And then the key moment. So Thursday, the 30th of July, all that morning, the politicians in St. Petersburg have been pestering the Tsar. Change your mind. Change your mind. Go for the full mobilization. And actually, the war minister telephoned
to make preparations, but very quietly and subtly, no full mobilization. Keep our troops back from the frontier. They play it very canonally, the French. Crucially, they say the key thing is, and I quote, this is from the Undersecretary for Foreign Affairs, Abel Ferry. He says, we must show to the English public and the English government that France, like Russia, will not be the first to fire. Make the Germans the bad guys, because that will bring in Britain on our side. So that's the atmosphere in France. And then the key moment. So Thursday, the 30th of July, all that morning, the politicians in St. Petersburg have been pestering the Tsar. Change your mind. Change your mind. Go for the full mobilization. And actually, the war minister telephoned|||做准备，但非常安静和微妙，不要进行全面总动员。让我们的军队远离边境。法国人玩得很有一套。至关重要的是，他们说最关键的事情是——我引用一下，这是外交部副国务卿阿贝尔·费里（Abel Ferry）的话。他说：“我们必须向英国公众和英国政府表明，法国和俄国一样，不会开第一枪。把德国人变成坏人，因为这会把英国拉到我们这一边。”这就是法国的气氛。然后是关键时刻。所以7月30日星期四，整个早晨，圣彼得堡的政治家们一直在纠缠沙皇。改变主意吧。改变主意吧。进行全面总动员吧。事实上，战争大臣打电话给
Nicholas at his palace, and Nicholas lost his temper on the phone and said, I will cut you off. I'm so determined not to do this. So they send Sergei Sazanov, the foreign minister, 3 p.m. that afternoon. He goes to the Peterhof Palace and he says, look, your majesty, there is no chance of avoiding war. This is where we are now. The Germans clearly are gagging for a fight. They can't wait to get started with us, which, of course, I mean, he genuinely believes, I think. We cannot delay any longer, please. And at first, I mean, it's so tragic when you think what's going to happen to almost all of these people. At first
尼古拉在他的宫殿里，他在电话里发了脾气，说：“我会切断与你的联系。我非常坚决不这么做。”于是他们在那天下午三点派出了外交大臣谢尔盖·萨扎诺夫。他前往彼得宫，对沙皇说：“陛下，看在眼里，已经没有避免战争的可能了。这就是我们现在的处境。德国人显然迫不及待地想打一仗。他们恨不得立刻就跟我们开战。”当然，我认为他是真心这么想的。我们不能再拖延了，求求您了。起初——我是说，一想到这些人的绝大多数将会遭遇什么，就觉得太悲惨了——起初
Nicholas says no. I quote he hates the idea of sending thousands and thousands of men to their deaths. I don't want to do this and Sazanov says please your majesty we have to do it or we will be smashed and so he wears him down and at four o'clock
尼古拉拒绝了。我引述他的话说，他讨厌把成千上万的人送去送死这个主意。“我不想这么做。”而萨扎诺夫说：“求求您了，陛下，我们必须这么做，否则我们就会被彻底粉碎。”于是他磨破了嘴皮子，在四点钟时
Sazanov telephones the army chief of staff who's a guy called General Januszkiewicz. And he says, it's done. We've got the order. Transmute the order. And by the way, when this call is over, smash the telephone. So the Tsar can't change his mind. And there's an amazing description.
萨扎诺夫给陆军参谋长打了个电话，那是一个叫亚努什凯维奇将军的人。他说：“成了。我们拿到命令了。下达命令吧。顺便说一句，这个电话打完后，把电话砸了。这样沙皇就没法改变主意了。”这里有一个精彩的描述。
The central telegraph office in St. Petersburg. There are rows and rows of telegraph operators sitting there quietly waiting. And then at just after four o'clock that afternoon, the general Yanishevich walks in with the order and he hands it to the chief operator. And nobody says anything. There's an atmosphere of deathly calm. And then a few seconds later, you hear the sound of clicking and tapping as the machines start to send out the order all across the russian empire my goodness so we're almost there so we've got one last episode to go if you can't wait for it you can hear it right now by joining the rest is history club at the rest is history.com but
圣彼得堡的中央电报局。一排排的电报员静静地坐在那里等待着。然后就在那天下午四点刚过，亚尼谢维奇将军拿着命令走了进来，把它交给了首席电报员。没有人说话。空气中弥漫着一种死一般的平静。几秒钟后，你听到咔哒咔哒和敲击的声音，机器开始向整个俄罗斯帝国发送命令。天哪，所以我们快要讲完了，所以我们还剩最后一集。如果你等不及了，现在就可以加入“The Rest is History”俱乐部收听，网址是theresthistory.com，但是
either way the abyss is yawning wide open now and in the final episode everyone will tumble into it so on that cheery note, goodbye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
无论如何，深渊现在正大张着嘴，在最后一集里，所有人都会跌落进去。带着这个欢快的心音，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘史》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的地方。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及优先购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。